Hey guys, hackers, Floyd here. And in this
video, we're going to get started with the web
application penetration testing series. Alright,
so a lot of you guys have been asking for this,
mostly because you want to learn the art of bug
bounty. And here is the series. So have worked
really, really hard on, you know, making it as
comprehensive as possible, we're going to get
started with setting up burp suite. So for those
of you who don't know, what works, who it is,
burp suite is essentially an integrated
platform for performing security testing
of web applications. Alright, so the first thing
you need to understand is that it will allow us to
intercept the data being sent between your browser
and the web application. So it's, it's a great way
of understanding how data is being transferred,
and how data can be manipulated, be manipulated,
between the client, and obviously, the web
application. Okay, so the tool we're going to be
using, as I said, is burp suite. And I'm currently
running power to us. So don't worry, if you're
running Windows or Kali Linux, it doesn't really
matter, all we need to do is just download and
install burp suite, it's pretty simple to get set
up, you don't have to register, you just download
the free community version. Now, obviously down
the line, you might choose to buy the professional
version, which I do recommend and I have used,
but I don't use it as often I'm not, you know,
specifically a web penetration tester, I'm more of
a more of an of a web server penetration tester.
So I really work with a different vectors. So
by default, you can choose to bite that one to
become experienced. And you know, you've chosen
whether this is the path that you want to pursue,
it's a fantastic path. I know a lot of people who
you know, make good money with bug bounty. So you
know, it's something that you can look into
as well. Alright, so let's get started with
setting up the proxy. Alright, so this is the
intercepting proxy that allows us to, obviously,
to intercept the data being sent to and from the
client and the, the web, the web application.
So to do that, we need we can just do it through
Firefox. So the browser I'll be using is Firefox,
you can use whatever you want. And by default, you
want to go into your preferences that can be found
here preferences, there we are. And you want to
go all the way into the bottom here. That way it
has the network proxy, and make sure you go into
settings, and you want to go into manual proxy
configuration. Alright, so this is where we're
going to configure it to be the localhost with
the port set at 8080. All right, and then you want
to make sure that this, you use the server proxy
for all protocols. So that is the proxy we're
going to be using and just hit OK. Alright, and
once that's done, you should be good there. Now
what you want to do is just open up burp suite, so
you can search for it, or I have it already on my
on my little Taskbar here. And I don't think I've
updated it for a while. So I probably need to do
that later. But for now, I'll just close that the
update prompt and it's going to prompt you Welcome
to burp suite. And it's going to say not depending
on the version that you've chosen to select
whether you've chosen the community version,
which is what I have here, or the free version, as
it's called, and you then have the pro version. So
by default, the community version only allows
you to use a temporary project, if you have the
professional version that allows you to save your
project, which is, you know, great functionality
as well. So just hit next and you just want
to use the verb defaults. And just hit start.
And just give that a few seconds to start it up.
Alright, and I'll explain the interface generally,
but we'll be looking more into how burp works.
In the next video, I just want to get you set up
with birth in this video, and you understand what
exactly is going on. Alright, so welcome to birth.
Now by default. Again, it may seem a little bit
intimidating mostly because if you're a beginner,
you have not heard of any of these of these words
here and you don't really know what they're doing.
Alright, so by default, you have your target proxy
spider scan into the repeater, sequencer, decoder,
compare extender, your project options, your user
options, and alerts, we'll be going through all
of this as we as we, you know, perform real
world testing on our on our vulnerable on our
vulnerable target, I'll be showing you how to
set up a dam vulnerable web application soon,
and many others but for now just focus on burp
suite. Alright, so by default, you want to just
go into proxy. Alright, and for some reason, I
already have some data here. So you know what, I'm
just going to leave that as it is, I just want to
turn our intercept off. So we're not intercepting
any traffic as of yet. And you want to go into
your options. And you want to make sure that your
proxy listeners, as you can see, burp proxy uses
listeners to receive incoming HTTP requests from
your browser. So you want to make sure that your
proxy is set as the as the one we set in Firefox,
which is the localhost 120 7.0 point 0.1 and the
port is 8080 and make sure that that is running.
Alright, you can also create your own and add it
here and you're going to To remove it, so you get
the idea. Now by default, if I just go back to
my intercept, if I just go back to my browser,
and this is where the real magic happens,
if I just, you know, if I just open this,
and I type in a simple test site example.com, and
I just hit enter, alright, it's going to load it
up here. But if we're going to burp suite, and I
go into HTTP history, you can see that by default,
there are some Firefox portals. You know, some
get methods here. But we'll be looking at all of
these methods or requests. By default, you can see
that the example.com, the example.com, one would,
you know, that we ended, you can see there is a
get request. And furthermore, if you go down to
the bottom here, you can see there is some more
information regarding now what a request are sent
to the web application. Or so by default, you can
see that the host was example.com. And it gives
you more information, like the Accept language,
the encoding, the connection. And if you look at
the headers, you can see that the header shows,
you know very clearly, you have your get host,
use agent accept language, the Accept encoding,
connection, etc, etc. So you might be a little bit
confused if this is your first time hearing about,
you know, headers, and the request and response
pairs. But don't worry about that we'll get to all
of this for now, if I just go back into intercept,
and let me just open up my browser here. And
we open something like the my web, my website,
would you say it just like.com. So before we do
that, I just want to hit intercept on. Alright,
so now it's going to intercept actively. And we
just go into Hs pro.com. And I hit go. Alright,
now by default is going to tell me that
essentially, the mic connection is not secure,
don't worry about this, just go into your and
just add this as an exception. There we are
made confirm exception. And now it's still not
going to load the website. And the reason being
is we have not forwarded the request. And they are
being intercepted by burp suite. Alright, so if I
go into back into burp suite, you can see that it
has started the intercept process. And by default,
you can see that we need to forward we need to
forward the request here. So if I just forward it,
let me just for that again, there we are, let
me just for them for hackers out there. Yeah,
that's the correct one. So all for this again.
And there. We also know hackers blade should
be up and running. And as you can see, I should
have loaded the site. Give that a few seconds.
There we are. Alright, so as you can see, that
is how you intercept the data that is being sent
from the client to the web application. And
furthermore, that's how you, you can analyze
the data being sent, and furthermore manipulated
to obviously find vulnerabilities within the web
application. Alright, so irregardless of all
of this, I know, this was very, very basic,
and it's not really covered anything in terms
of web application penetration testing. But
don't worry about that, you know, we start off
really, really simple. And we build on that.
We're going to get started with spidering, more
specifically spidering, with burp suite. And,
you know, the purpose of this video or this
tutorial, is to help you understand the
spidering process and how to go about doing
it with a burp suite. Alright, so there's
going to be a little bit of theory here, but
I'll be explaining a lot of things. So again,
this video is really focused on understanding
spidering. Now, before we get started with that, I
just wanted to let you know that the target or our
web application that we're going to be targeting,
we're going to be attacking is the damn vulnerable
web application. Now, if you don't know what the
damn vulnerable web application is, that's fine,
you can just Google it. And I'll probably make a
video on how to get it installed on Kali Linux.
But what I would recommend if you're, you know,
beginner, or even if you're a professional in
hacking, probably one of the best things that you
need to have, you know, in your kit is Metasploit
able to write and for the simple reason that it
contains, first and foremost a vulnerable
operating system. And secondly, it contains
all the vulnerable web applications that we will
be using at one stage during this series. Okay,
so we're going to be starting off with the
damn vulnerable web application. As I said,
it comes pre installed with meta splittable, too.
So all you need to do is get the local IP address
on your mat, exploitable to virtual machine,
which in my case is 190 2.1 68 point 1.1 a dupe.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to open up
my browser, and I'm just going to open up that
webs that IP address point 1.1 or two, and just
give it a few seconds to load up. As you can see,
there we are, that's made exploitable too. And
it's going to prompt us to select what vulnerable
web app we want to use. In this case, we're going
to select the DV w A, which is the dam vulnerable
web application. So just click on that and it's
going to ask you for your admin and password in
this case for your username and password Sorry
about that, in this case Your username is admin
and the password is password. Alright, so just
hit login, and it's going to log you into the
damn vulnerable web application. Now we'll be
looking at this at a more in a later video. And
the reason is we have to go through all of these
options. But for now, if you go to the login,
just remember where it was, if I can just go
to the security, so to the dam vulnerable web
application security, at the moment, it was high,
because I was actually performing some tests on
it, but just change it to medium or low. But for
now, you wouldn't be using it. I was just letting
you know what web application we're going to be
using. Alright, that being said, let's move on
to burp suite. All right, and we can I can start
explaining the spidering process. Right. So let
me just open up burp suite. So I've updated it to
the latest version. I think I'm running Catalina
next now in the previous video, I was running
parrot. So I think there should be an update,
but I could be wrong. So let's just give that a
few seconds to start up yet there is an update. So
I'll do that later. And we'll just click on create
our temporary project and use the bap default and
start that. Okay, so once that starting, let
me explain what spidering is right now the
purpose of spidering is to identify our scope,
alright, or what, what we want to scan. Now this
is not exactly scanning, and we'll be looking at
scanning. But essentially spidering is the process
of mapping out our web application, and is very,
very useful for finding links and and web forms,
which is also very important because it will
allow us to then furthermore, attack the web forms
manipulate headers, etc, etc. Right now, when you
talk about automatic spidering with burp suite,
it essentially when when burp is spidering,
it follows links and it will, it will start
following links and it will start identifying for
files, folders and forms from the web application.
And it will, the great thing about this is it will
record all the requests and responses while it's
performing the the old spidering process. Okay,
so once you have a burp suite opened up here, you
can let me just expand it. So we have a greater
picture of what's going on exactly. Sorry, if my
virtual machine is a little bit slow, I need to
configure it correctly. Anyway, what you want to
do is we have looked at the proxy check section,
let's look at the spider section. And in here,
this is a very, very simple menu and to understand
it, you can see that we have two tabs available,
we have the control tab and we have the options
tab. Alright, the control tab. Essentially,
if we just click if I just look, if we look at it,
as you can see, these settings are used to monitor
and control the web spider. So it allows you to
stop to start and stop the burp spidering. And
you can also clear the cues. Alright, when you
look at the options, which is right here, sorry
about that, when you look at the options, there
are a lot of options, we'll be looking at them,
I will be looking at them in a second. Sorry
about that, I actually got an email, apologies
that. Let's get started. Now with the control
section. So the control section, it will all
we are able to control the spider status where we
can stop it and started and you know, furthermore,
we can clear the cues that already exists there.
Alright, we then have the spider scope where we
can, we can define our own scope. And depending
on what we want to spider, we look at that in a
few seconds. And finally, we look at the well if
we look in the Options section here, we have the
crawler settings which allow us to specify the way
the spider is going to crawl for the web content
on the web application, we'll be looking at the
maximum link depth and what that means passive
spidering that allows us to essentially spider to
continue spidering when we are looking through or
we're going through the web application, we're
performing requests and responses when we're
performing requests. As for the form submission,
this is probably something that we'll be looking
at in the next video and we'll be doing this.
Practically we will be actually performing the
we'll be performing the spidering process. But
for now, let me see what else Yes, the request
headers. The request headers are used to you can
manipulate essentially the headers. If you've
learned about HTTP headers, by the way, I really
want to cover HTTP because it's very important
that you understand how the ad is work. But we'll
be looking at this all in advance. But now let's
start off with the spider status. Well, not really
with the spider status. But looking at the control
tab. If you look at the spider scope, you can see
that you can it will use the default suite scope,
which is defined in the target tab. If you just
click on use a custom scope, you can see that
Okay, first, you over, if you just click on this
little cog here, you can restore the default, you
can load your own and you can save the options.
So that's just to do with that. Now when you talk
about using the advanced scope here is where you
can essentially this is where you specify what you
want to map so you can specify a host, the port,
etc, etc. Okay, again, we'll be looking at all
of this as We move along. But for now, we're just
going to use the default suite scope, we can just,
if once you click on that, it's going to start the
spidering process, but we don't need it right now.
So I'm just going to come just going to pause
it. And if we move on to the options now the
Options tab has a lot of stuff that we need to
look into. First and foremost, we have the CRO,
the crawler settings. Alright. So when you're
talking about the basic options, for example,
we can specify what the spider will crawl for.
So it you can choose to select for robots,
the robots dot txt file, which is very important
because it shows you, you know, exclusions,
you then can detect, you can ignore the links to
non text content, you can request the root of all
directories very important stuff. But again,
you can customize this to your liking. Now,
one of the things I would recommend that you'd
not touch with, if you do not know what you're
doing yet is the maximum link. That's right, the
maximum link depth is essentially the number of
links you want the spider to, to essentially, to
crawl or to map. Now by default five is in my,
in my, in my situation, or in my case, what I
like doing is alternating between three to five,
anything higher than that will usually overload
the web application, and it will cause it to lag
or to respond very, very slowly. And, you know,
again, that might not mean a lot right now,
but trust me, when you'll actually be performing
the penetration test on the web application,
you really need a good response. Otherwise,
you have your time to live, etc, etc. Okay,
so let's look at what passive spidering is,
alright, so as passive spidering. And said,
is essentially just, it allows you to continue
scanning, you know, or going through, or
actually performing your requests how as as it, it
essentially allows you to continue the spidering
process as you're performing any other tasks.
So as you can see, passes by during monitors,
monitors traffic through the burp proxy to update
the sitemap without making any new requests,
right. So passively spiders you browse, you can
also select the link depth associated with proxy
requests now this, I would recommend keeping
it at zero to two. And that's because again,
you do not want a very, very deep alert link
depth in the sense that you're also going to
be performing your own requests, and you'll be
doing many other things you could be looking
at the decoder or you could be looking
at, you could be focusing on the target,
and you don't want it again to to slow
down the web application. Alright,
so form submission. Again, this is something that
I said we'll be talking about in the next video,
because it is quite advanced. And we'll get
started with the damn vulnerable web application
there. Moving on to the spider engine, we'll be
looking at application login as well. But for now,
just we'll just keep over that when we talk
about the spider engine. Alright, these settings
control the engineers for making HTTP requests one
spidering. Right. So this allows you to change the
number of threads you want to use. And as I said,
using more than we can see right now it's at 10,
what I would recommend is still keeping it within
the range of two to five are all you might,
you might cause the web application to slow
down. And these are more advanced settings that
you can use dependent on timing. All right,
and we've talked about the request headers,
they allow you to modify the way the spider will
we look towards the web applications, for example,
you could you could edit the the device that is
being used. And you could change it, for example,
into a mobile device and you get the idea you you
essentially allows you to to change the request
headers. And from that, obviously, you'll get
a response back, dependent on what you changed.
Alright, so that was the spidering, or actually
the theory revolving on spidering. Now we'll
be looking at how spidering really works in the
next video. I know some of you may not like this
that I actually went through through theory, and I
haven't talked about doing anything. But remember,
it's very, very important to understand what
exactly is happening behind spidering. And
in the next video, we'll actually get
started with the spidering process.
Get started with brute forcing with the rates
or our vulnerable web application of choice is
going to be the damn vulnerable web application,
as we discussed in the previous video, alright,
and I'm going to be using meta exploitable
to as our as my server. By default,
you can install medispa, you can install the damn
vulnerable web application on your Kali Linux,
and you can host it on your local on your local
server. And you can you can then perform your
attacks. But I like running it from another
virtual machine. And as you can see, I'm running
it on the Metasploit able to virtual machine. And
by default, it's connected to my local network
and it's bridged. So you can see that my local IP
address is 190 2.168 point 1.1 or two. Alright, so
I already have the damn vulnerable web application
open as you can see it is running on the that IP
address of the meta splittable to virtual machine
on the the damn vulnerable web application. So for
those of you asking why I'm using Metasploit able
to instead of meta splittable. Three, it's because
Metasploit able to has a much larger choice in
terms of vulnerable web applications. And it's
really good for practicing. Alright, so make
sure you're logged into your damn vulnerable
web application, you need the default username
is admin and the password is password. Alright,
it's really very simple. Alright, by default, In
this video, we're going to set our security level
too low. If you don't know how to do that, you can
go into your deverbal web application security.
And you can set that too low, and you can just
hit submit. The reason we're setting it too low is
because most logins Are you know, if you look at
the real world, if you're talking about big sites,
this attack may very well work on sites that
are older, or sites that have not been updated,
or sites that don't have good security, you'll
be shocked to find some really big companies
that actually don't have any login protection,
or brute force protection for that matter. Now,
that being said, what I was talking about is if
we go to brute force, you can see that we have
a login prompt here. Now I forgotten the username
and password, and we're going to be brute forcing
it live. Alright, but before we do that, we
need to actually start our birth. Alright, so
start up that suite. And you can see I'm using the
Community Edition. And it is the latest version,
right? So make sure that yours is the latest
version, obviously, for obvious reasons. And
we're just going to start a temporary project
because I don't use the pro version. And we're
going to hit use the birth defaults when you start
work. Alright, give that a few seconds to start
the to start back. And now you want to make sure
you you're using the proxy. So we're going to go
into preferences, and advanced and whoops, burp
is oh opened up, let me just go into my proxies,
network settings. And we make sure that
it's using the manual proxy configuration,
which is the localhost 120 7.0 point 0.1. And
the port is 8080. We're gonna hit OK, excellent.
Now we need to move into burp back again. And
we want to make sure that we go into proxy,
and the intercept is set to off. All right,
the reason we're setting the intercept off,
is because I just want to show you something
first. Now by default intercept essentially just
means that you're not intercepting the request,
the requests and the responses being sent from
the web application to your browser. Okay, so
we have already set the proxy for the browser,
but we're not intercepting. So if we just test a
random username like test, and we say a password
like 12345, you can see if I hit login, it's
going to tell me that that is incorrect. Now,
if I set the intercept to on to see the request,
let me just turn it on. And we can now reload this
we can say test and the password 12345. We can
see that now it's for some reason, let me just
forward that after actually just turn that off.
And we now see log in. And for some reason that
is not allowing us because you have to reload.
Alright, so now if I hit intercept on, and whoops,
let me just open up my browser and hit the parcel
1345. Log In. For some reason it's going to,
it's going to slowly reloading here. I probably
there we are. Alright, so I've reloaded the page.
And as you can see, now the intercept is on and
we go back to burp, you can see that we got the
get request being sent by the web application.
Now let's inspect it for a while now we'll be
looking at what all of this really means but by By
default, the most important thing right now is the
get request. Alright, so you can see that the get
request has two values here. It has the username
and the and the password. Now the values again are
not important we're going to be brute forcing the
values but it's very important to get the fields
that we're using here. Now what am I talking about
if you look at the cookie you can see the security
is low. And if you were to edit the value and for
the package, you can set it too high that is basic
stuff that's good stuff right? But now we want to
brute force this login. Alright, and how do we do
that you can see the first thing we need to do is
we're going to be using the intruder alright so
if you're a bit confused about what the in today's
Don't be worried intruder is essentially allow
allows us to edit the parameters, it allows us to
edit the requests and then obviously edit them and
manipulate them so we can get the desired results.
Now the great thing about there in the intruder
is it allows us to perform attacks like the brute
force, etc, etc. Alright, but now what we need
to do is we need to send this request into the
intruder so that we can send our own response.
Alright, so we're going to right click and send
to intruder. So we just send it to intruder. And
once it's sent to the intruder, you can just hit
forward. Alright, we don't need window, we don't
need that GET request anymore. So now you want to
go into the intruder and you want going to your
positions. And as you can see in your positions
you have got you have got the get request that
we were we just intercepted. And now you can
see something really interesting. It's highlighted
for you all the different payloads. Okay, all the
different fields that we can brute force for. By
default we have the username value, the password
value, the login value, we have the F the SF ID
value, we have the the cookie value, no No, no,
we don't need all of these The only values that we
need The username and the password value. So the
most important thing you need to do right now is
you need to clear just hit clear. Alright, oops,
sorry, not that clear. I beg, I beg your apology
there. I sorry, I didn't mean that what I'm trying
to say is I'm sorry, just clear, just hit clear.
And as you can see, now, no values are being
selected to be brute force against. So now we need
to select them manually. But before that, we're
going to be using the the cluster bomb attack
type. Alright, the reason we're using the cluster
bomb attack type is because we are going to be
using two values, we are brute forcing against
two values. Remember that, okay, and these need to
be set in, in combination. So that means it's much
better to use a cluster bomb because essentially,
you're clustering to values that need to be that
need to be tested against the login, the login
application, or the login form together, alright,
so in a combination, so we need to select cluster
bomb. And now we need to select the values because
those are the those are that is what we want to
brute force again. So just highlight the value,
it doesn't matter the password or the username
is just highlight it, and you want to hit Add.
Alright, so just hit Add. And as you can see,
we have selected that, you know, going to the
password, and you want to highlight that as well.
And you just want to add that, as you can see
now once you have added that those are the two
values we're going to be brute forcing against,
make sure that none of the others are selected
none of the other values. Once that is done,
you're you're almost there now. Now you want to
go into your payloads. Right now in your payloads,
you want to make sure that your payload set is set
to two, which is your username and your password.
So let's start off with your payload set as
payload one, all right as your payload type,
make sure that that is a simple list. Because
you can see we were only targeting usernames
and passwords. So we don't need, you know, a
runtime file, or we're not changing anything,
you know, dependent on Unicode etc, you get the
idea. Okay, so simple list. And now you're going
to your payload options, which is where you select
your user list or your password list or your word
list. Now, we're not using a word list. But if
you want to, you can if you're performing this
on a real site, which I don't recommend unless
you have written permission. Now since we're
using this in our penetration testing lab, we are
going to just add the default usernames and said
the security of the site is low. And it's not
really a complex a brute force to crack. Okay,
so what we want to do is, we want to make sure
we have set payload set to one, which is going
to be for our usernames. So now we can go into
load where you can load your default usernames
and your passwords or your word lists, but by
default, we're going to add our own Alright,
so we're gonna say, whoops, we, for some, we're
just gonna say, we're going to type in a now like
the commonly used usernames, alright, so something
like admin, administrator whoops, for some reason,
actually, let me just remove these blank values
there. admin now administrator, administrator, let
me just type that back in. administrator, like, so
administrator, for those of you telling me that my
typing is bad. That's because my microphone
is right in front of me, and I can't really
see what I'm typing administrator. Let's see what
else what are the default ones like we have root,
we have password. Actually, we're not setting
the passwords right now. So we can just type in
the default ones like this. All right, so we can
say test, you know, the default ones, user one,
whatever you think could be the most commonly used
ones, okay? Or if you know what the username is,
that is even better. So we're gonna add all the
usernames. Alright, so we've added the usernames
that we want to use. Now by default, again, I'm
saying you can use a word list if you want to just
go into load and select the word list. Now we want
to select our passwords, right? So we can go into
the payload set to. And as you can see, now we
can add our own values. Now we can use the default
word lists that come with Kali Linux. So if I go
into my root, and I'm going to use them, share and
reselect word lists, let me just find where word
lists are. If I can find them, there we are word
lists. And they are the ones that work great for
me in the Metasploit folder. And you can look for
the default passwords. As you can see, you have
your database default passwords, you have your
default, user password for services, that's also
great. It has a great list of of default usernames
and passwords that you can use. But for me, I'm
not going to use this because we are sticking
to the basics. And now you want to add your own
password. So we can select again, some randomly,
you know, commonly used passwords. So pass, you
can say password. Let's see what else admin, you
know, admin again, whoops, let me just remove that
one admin. Route, you can use route. Let's see,
let me think 12345. That was the one that I've
seen many network administrators using 12345.
And you get the idea. All right, so we've set our
two payloads. payload one is set for usernames.
payload two is set for passwords. Excellent. All
right now, we have selected our payload types we
have selected we have added our payload options.
We don't need to look at payload processing that
is advanced once That's done, what you want to
do is going to intruder and start the attack.
Alright, and now it's going to tell you that the
Community Edition of burp contains a demo version,
but it's essentially telling you that the process
is going to be slow. Alright, so we're gonna hit
OK. And it's going to start at the attack. As you
can see, it's going through all the combinations.
And as you can see, the combinations that we
have here are 25, and is going to go through
all of them. Now, one great thing that you need to
do here or one important thing that you need to do
is you need to understand the the the status codes
that the server or the web application is sending
back. Now, that's a good way of, of understanding
what password is correct? And what what username
is correct and what password is not correct.
Okay. So if we look now, at the, at the results,
as you can see that it's finished, it's going
through the brute force attack, we check the
status, the status is still the same, we have a
status to 200. If we look at the length, right,
the length is going to be still the same. But you
have to look for things that are not that are not
matching. So for example, you can see that the
length here that was returned was 4948. And it's
not, it's not following the format of the others.
So that means that this could be the username
and password, don't worry about the status, the
status will still remain the same, regardless of
that. But when we'll be looking at Advanced Server
penetration testing, that's something important.
So you can see that the get that we've got here is
very important. Now if we look at the if we look
at the response that will be sent. Right there,
you can see the response. And if we render it,
you can see that if it was successful, it will
tell us that we've logged in successfully. So let
me just browse down all the way as you can see,
welcome to the password protected area admin.
And there you go, that is the username and the
password is admin and password. Now again, this
was really simple. Again, you can you can increase
the security if you're practicing on your own. But
you can see that this really works. And this is
how to utilize burp for advanced stuff like brute
forcing. Now again, most of the advanced websites
nowadays have great content management systems
that have the security plugins that essentially
prevent you from brute forcing or lock you out.
But most of the oldest sites, you'll be, you'll
be actually quite shocked to find out that they
are brute forces, they are log informed sorry,
are not protected. Now we've already logged in,
and you can see that the default username is
admin, and the password is password. Okay, so you
can look at the role. The raw HTTP here, you can
look at the request and the response. Or you can
look at them and you can inspect them, if that's
what you do. And you can look at the headers,
what's being sent, all that good stuff. But that
was going to be it for this video. And now if we
just go back into burp, let me just go into my
proxy. And I'm going to disable intercept. And
we can try and log in here. So we know that
the admin username is admin and the password
is password. So let me log in. And welcome to
the password protected admin area fantastic.
In this video, we're going to be looking at
selecting our verbs with our target in web suite,
adding it to our scope, and then finally spidering
it as my vulnerable operating system, I'm going to
be using the Matilda de which comes pre installed
on Metasploit able to so you should download Well,
I would recommend that you download Metasploit
able to, it's a fantastic option for any of you
who are just getting into penetration testing
offers multiple vulnerable web applications
and vulnerable systems that you can practice
with. So again, it's something that I really,
really recommend. That being said, as you can
see, I have made exploitable to virtual machine
running. And I have already looked at my local IP
address, you can do that by typing in if config
that will display to you your your current network
interface and your local IP address. Because we
are doing this in our virtual penetration testing
lab. Alright, so let's go back to Kali Linux now.
And I'm going to open up my browser, make sure
you get your IP address. And as I said, again,
we're going to be using motility. So if you don't
know what Mattila day is Mattila day is simply a
vulnerable web application. And the reason I'm
switching I'm switching from the damn vulnerable
web application is because I want to show you
a few, I really want to make it a bit diverse
in terms of the web applications that we use.
Alright, so let's get started now. Now I already
have the IP address of my virtual machine opened
up here in my browser, as you can see, 190 2.1
68 point 1.14. So if I reload this, you can see
that it indeed is the meta splittable to server
and I can just go ahead and click on Mattila
day. Alright, now what I should do now is go
into my preferences, you can do that by opening a
new tab. So let me just open a new tab here going
into preferences, and then selecting advanced and
network and finally settings. And then you want to
make sure you select a manual proxy configuration.
And then make sure it's using the localhost proxy,
which is wondering 7.0 point 0.1 Port 8080 and
hit OK. Once that's done, we know that burp suite
can intercept. Not that we want to do that in this
video, we just want to, we want to have a look at,
we want to map the web, the web application.
Alright, so we're not going to change anything
in Mattila day. But I'm going to be showing you
some pretty interesting things in this video.
So now we should start up burp suite community.
Now I'm going to be explaining something at the
end of the video that is really important. And it
is in regards to the community version, and the
professional version of burp suite and what what
the differences are and why you will need at some
point to get the professional version. Okay, so
I'm going to select a temporary project, I'm using
the community version as of right now, hit Next,
use the bird default, and I'm going to start up.
Alright, so it's going to start burp suite. And
let me just minimize the browser here. So give
that a few seconds to start up. And once it starts
up, what you want to do immediately is turn off
the proxy, we want to stop in the intercepting
because we are not intercepting any requests,
or we are not inserting any responses. So go back
into your target. And now we can get started with
with actually reloading the page right here. So
let's reload that. And we should be able to see
what's going on. And we should have the sitemap.
Alright, so let me just open up the burp suite
here. Fantastic. Alright, so now you can see
something very interesting has happened here.
In our target. And sitemap, we have the files that
were discovered here. Well, essentially, we have
the web server that then has the modality folder,
which is our target. Now before I get into any of
that, the site map will show you the current
site map. Obviously a site map is essentially
sorry about that a site site map is essentially
the structure or the format of the webpage,
and how the web page was constructed and how it
will function in regards to every other piece of
content. Okay, so the first thing that we need to
do, or we'll be looking at is actually selecting
our target, which in this case, again, is Mattila
day. And you can do that by right clicking and
hitting add to scope. All right, so you might
be asking what exactly the scope means? Well,
a scope essentially allows us to define our
automated spidering. And what this means is
we are focusing our only on our target, we're
not going to focus on the reference links,
like you can see here, for example, we have to
it as a reference link, backtrack, dynamic drive,
Eclipse, etc, etc, you get the idea. So scoping
is essentially selecting our target, isolating it,
so that we only see what we need to see. And
the obviously the results that we want to see.
So I'm going to right click on Mattila day,
and I'm going to hit Add to scope. Alright,
so now it's going to say you've added an item to
to the target scope, do you want that proxy to to
stop sending out scope items out of scope items
to the history of the other bedtools? Yes, again,
we want to make sure that we are we clear out all
the junk that we don't need. Now you might have
noticed? Well, that's essentially happened, but
nothing is really changed. And as you can see,
it's gonna tell you here logging of out of scope,
proxy traffic is disabled, don't worry about that,
just leave it as it is, if you want to re
enable it, you can go ahead but right now you
don't need to do that. Okay, so we've looked
at how to add our target to the scope. Now,
let's look at spidering is essentially the
the first and the most important step of web
application penetration testing. Alright,
it is it deals with or it is in it is in
relation with footprinting. And this is why I
bring the comparison from penetration testing
to obviously web application penetration testing
it is to deal it essentially deals with crawling
through the website. And then it records all the
files, the links and the methods and the methods
that it can get. And that helps us build an idea
of how the web application is structured, how it
works. And then finally, we can learn how we can
break through it. What we need to do is we need to
spider our target. Well, we have added it to the
scope, which is great. And now we need to spider
it. So what we're going to do is we're going to
we're going to use spider and this will help us
identify all the links and the parameters that we
need. Again, as I said, it's like footprinting. So
what you want to do is right click on your
target, which in this case is Mattila day,
and you want to spider this branch. Alright,
so I'm going to spider this branch. And no,
something interesting is going to start happening.
As you can see, it's going to start getting all
the links all the resources that it can, and it's
going to prompt you with here a submit form. Okay,
now, what you can do is just ignore the form,
there'll be quite a few essentially, these are
default login forms where it's asking you to
enter credentials that you might want to enter,
let's say you, you're performing whitebox, then
Richard testing and you have the details. You
can again log in like this and perform internal
penetration tests. But we're going to assume
that you're you do not know your penetration,
you're essentially performing a penetration
test on the security. So I'm going to ignore
all of these forms. Okay. And as you can see,
there's another one right there and the spidering
is probably continuing. Now if you want to view
the status of these By doing, you can go into
spider. And as you can see you have the status
of the spider. And once it's done, you will see
that the requests made will stop changing. And
the bytes transferred, will also stop changing so
we can stop the spider. Now you noticed something
that we were faced with those are form login
prompts. Now, you can choose to enter them as
a prompt or as you're prompted, but the better
way of doing this is to actually you actually do
this automatically. And you can do this by going
into spider. And you want to go into options,
and you want to go in to your application login.
Alright. Now, if you look at the form submission,
it is essentially what it's doing is is going to
use the default form submissions that you would
find in a database. So for example, we have male,
first name, last name, surname, name, address,
you get the idea. So those are default values
that one would, one would be expected to find. Now
we're looking at the application login. As you can
see, its option is set to prompt for guidance, we
want to change this to automatically submit these
credentials. Now in here you can enter default
credentials. Or if you have an idea of what the
credentials you might expect to find. Now, this is
where creativity and sheer information gathering
comes into play. So if you need a new the default,
you know, usernames and passwords, you can enter
them here. Now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to enter a string that is, well, I've used it
before in performing SQL injection, and we'll talk
about SQL injection because it is very advanced.
If you know SQL injection, or you have you have
an idea or experience with the databases, you
might understand what this string means. Alright,
so for my username, I'm going to change that to
admin, quotation mark and say, or one equal one,
and two dashes. All right space and a dash. Now
you don't need to worry what this means for now,
please do not stress about this, I will explain
it when the time is right. All right. So leave
the password as it is. And don't worry about that.
Now, we had, we don't need to change anything in
terms of these tabs, we talked about these tabs
in the theory section. And now we can go back into
our control and target. And finally, we can spider
the application again, once more so that we can
enter the we can essentially process the strings
that we that we just entered in terms of the user
name, so I'm going to right click and spider this
branch. Okay, so it's going to start spidering.
And if we look at the spider, you can see that the
the spidering is complete. And you can essentially
clear the cues if you want to clear the clear them
like so. And you can keep on running it depending
on what you want to do. Okay, so I'm just
going to pause it. And now we have essentially
spidered the web application. And you might be
asking, well, I've seen a few reference sites,
that's not helping much, you know, we don't need
twitter.com or you know, sizzle js, this might
give us a basic idea of what types of sites are
linked to to the web application. But in reality,
you can see we have hackers.org not not very
important information at all. Now, what if
we click on the Mattila day folder? Oh, look at
that. That's really interesting. Now that is very,
very important. What has happened here is it's
given us the structure of the web application,
this is vitally important. All right now, again,
as I'm saying, you can look at how the website
or the web application is structured. So in
documentation, you can see you can go ahead
and read the documentation, you can look at
the images that the website has the styles,
so you can inspect the entire site and understand
what exactly is going on here or get an idea of
what the person who developed the website was
thinking. And then finally, out of experience,
or as we'll be looking at out of knowledge, you
can actually understand how to exploit the system.
And that we will be talking about discovering
hidden files, hidden files, like admin pages,
login pages, you know, that really juicy stuff.
And we'll be talking about that in the next video.
And that's because that sweet Community Edition
does not support or have allow you to use that
feature. So what I'm going to do in the next
video, I'm going to be using burp suite Pro,
and also show you an alternative program. I'm sure
you've heard of it. That also works on Windows.
Of course, that's how it works on Windows. But
I'm not really a Windows fan when it comes down
to penetration testing. So that being said, we
have essentially spider the application we have
the structure of the web application. And now we
need to look at something also very interesting
as we have already talked about it. Let me just
complete. Let me just show you how to get rid of
all of these reference links and to essentially
show the items in the scope only. So what you
can do is just click on filter right here, this
little bar here is the filter bar. So click on it,
and it's going to show you bring up this smaller
window and you want to focus on the filter by
request type and make sure you check show only in
scope items. This will essentially filter all the
results to show you only links or resources or
files that are within the scope. So once that's
done, just click back on the filter. And as you
can see it has got rid of all the junk that you do
not need whatsoever. And now you can essentially
look at the, the requests and the responses and
analyze them accurately defined to your scope. And
this will essentially, it will stop confusing you,
I've seen many beginners make this mistake where
they don't define the scope. They do not know
what the target is, and they're getting links that
are not even relate to the website that they're,
they're trying to perform the penetration test
on. Now, since you know this knowledge, this
will help you get a solid foundation. And again,
you can start logging out of skip out of scope
proxy traffic when you want. Again, that's very
nice that they add that button right over there.
Alright, so now you only have the files that
you require, or the files that you're currently
performing the penetration test only. Now I know
this, this video was slightly, there was not a
lot of action. But again, it is very important
that you get this in the next video, we'll be
looking at how to how to discover hidden files
or files in general that you are not supposed to
find. Okay. And that can be done by right clicking
and going into engagement tools. As you can see,
it is defined to the professional version of burp
suite. And we will be going into discover content
where I'll be explaining to you how to find
things like the login page or the configuration
page. Some things that web developers, you know,
actually just may try to hide them. But if it's
actually found, can really exploit the website
or can lead to the exploitation of the website.
We're going to start looking at how to discover
hidden files. But before that, I just want to take
you through a few things. Alright, so let's start
off with what OS base or o w SP. Alright, so what
does that mean? Well, essentially what it means,
or what it stands for is the open web application
security project. Alright, and its goal. Well,
essentially, it is a nonprofit organization
whose goal is focused on improving the security of
software. All right, so its job is to improve the
security of software. Now this project, the O w
SP, or the open web application security project,
created a tool called as the Zed attack proxy. Or
as you know, it the zap, many people like calling
it zap. And I'm sure most of you have heard
of it. And you might have been, you might be
leaning towards burp suite a little bit more. But
I can guarantee you that zap is one of my favorite
tools. And I use it because firstly, it's free.
And for the people like for the students I teach,
I usually tell them to start with zap because if
you get zap, you'll automatically get burp suite.
And you only need burp suite when you're moving
into an enterprise environment where you know,
burpsuite is the recommended tool. And it is the
tool that you must use to adhere to certain rules
and ethics. That being said zap is a fantastic
tool. It's absolutely free. As you can see the
old w SP Zed attack proxy proxy, which is,
you know, abbreviated as zap is one of the
world's most popular free security tools and is
actively maintained by hundreds of international
volunteers, right. So it helps you find security
vulnerabilities in your web applications while
you're developing and testing applications. So
again, if you're a web application developer,
this is also a fantastic tool for you. And as I
said, it's going to be a fantastic alternative
to do burp suite. All right now that's not
to say that burp is bad. burp is more of a
enterprise an enterprise developed software.
As I've mentioned in the for the first video
of this series, burp is focused on professionals.
Now that's not to say that zap isn't, but you'll
get the idea. Alright, so I'm going to be making
a separate video on installing zap and I'm going
to make a video on how to get accustomed to the
interface because it is slightly different. And
the language or English used for the interface is
again very well obviously very different but it is
quite different. So again, getting used to it was
also something that is quite helpful because we'll
be needing some of the enterprise features and on
only a tool like zap will be a great alternative.
However, if you do have burp suite Pro, go ahead,
it will it will just be the same thing. As I
mentioned in the previous video, it's really
very easy to to follow up where we left. Okay,
that being said, it runs on the same network
proxy, it runs on the localhost. So make sure
you're running it on the localhost and on port
8080. I'll be showing you how to change the port
if you so feel you want to. That's also another
great thing about us as AP is it allows you to
change the proxies. So I have Mattila day opened
up here and it is again running on my Metasploit
able to virtual machine and it's running
on the IP address my local IP address 190
2.1 68 point 1.104 as you can see Mattila day.
Alright, so that's working perfectly. So let me
just leave those other tabs open because again,
there's no there's no real harm. Okay, so, again,
you can configure the material at a security level
if that's what you want, you know to do to make
things harder. But I'm just going to be showing
you the focus of this video, which is how to find
hidden files. Now, you might be asking, why do
we need to find hidden files? Or why do we need
to discover these hidden files or hidden files?
Firstly, are the files like admin login pages,
you know, maybe a robots dot txt, but that's not
really something that's hidden nowadays. It could
be a txt containing maybe usernames, you know,
something really weird, or, you know, pardon
my English or pardon my language, something dumb
that the web developers left behind, or, you know,
just not configured correctly. And you'll see
what I mean in a few seconds. All right. So again,
these are the files that are hidden, and
you will not find them after spidering,
your web application or website. Alright, so let's
get started with zap. As you can see, I have the
logo right here on my it's added to my favorites,
let me just launch it, give it a few seconds, and
it should start up. There we are, the zap, give it
a few seconds again, and make sure you update it
usually the updates for the modules very, very
regularly. So make sure you update them to the
latest version, as they improve the speed and so
on and so forth. Alright, so it's going to prompt
you here, do you want to persist the substation,
that means Do you want to save this app session,
I don't, I do not want to persist the session at
this moment in time. So I'm going to start. Again,
don't worry, if you're not familiar with the
interface, I'll be going through it in another
video because it deserves Now you might be a
little bit overwhelmed. But do not worry, do
not stop going to you know URLs to attack that may
seem really really tempting. But again, you know,
let's take it nice and easy. So let's talk about
the proxy, how to change the proxies. So to do
that, you can go into your cog right here, as
you can see, or you can go into tools and go
into options. Alright, but I like going into this
little cog here. And once you press on, once you
click on the cog, let me just enlarge that, you
will see that you have this huge menu. And again,
as I said, zap is a really advanced tool, and in
some cases can totally replace burp suite. Now,
looking at the proxies, you want to go for
the local proxies right here. It's obviously
starting with L. So local proxies, and make
sure that the address is hosted on localhost.
And you can change the port if you're using burp
suite and stuff, like you're just using both the
applications at the same time, or you're running
something on localhost already. So you can change
it to something like 8081, whatever you feel
is comfortable for you. Okay, so that's how to
change your proxies. And if you're running the
ad net, you can also go check this and that you
should be good there, if you don't find that the
proxy is working. So just hit OK. Alright, now,
you see that there is no draya We are not going to
be looking at intercepting right now, but we will
be looking at that in a few in probably the next
videos, the advanced videos with SAP. Alright,
so let me just reload the material a page. And
as you can see, I'm running the proxy. So I'm
just going to reload the page. And as you can
see, we are not intercepting actively. So Whoa,
what's this? Well, we got some files here. Let me
just reload the page one more time. And there we
are, we are getting some results. So we get the IP
190 2.1 68 point 1.14. That's the server and if we
just click on this drop down here, we get request.
So you can analyze the get request. If that's what
you want, you can right click, and then analyze.
All right now will we not be looking at that right
now because I want to focus on finding the or
discovering the hidden files. So what we'll do
is we want to click on the utility folder. Now one
of the great things I like about zap is it already
gives you the file structure or the website
structure immediately here. Alright, so again,
so you have your images folder, which has it,
the images there, you have JavaScript styles,
and your all the resources in regards to the
website that it could find naturally. Alright.
So if we, if we just look at the bottom here, you
can see that it it's showing you a timestamp with
the method that the URL, and it gives you the
the code which means the pages in this case,
the 200 code means the page was found, you have
the reason you have the RTT, the size, the alert,
as you can see, it's telling us we have a high
alert here. Now don't worry about that. Again,
these are things that you know will be will
really be tempting, but again, let's take it slow.
Alright, so the first thing you want to do or you
need to do is to right click here, and you want to
go to attack and hit spider. Alright, so we want
to spider the website or the web application and
start scan Do not touch anything here. Just make
sure it's using the appropriate server address
and just hit scan. Right now it's going to spider
the entire web application and it's going to give
you a little progress bar here. You can pause
it or stop it which is also great to see at the
bottom you should have also noticed that you have
your tabs here that work really really well. And
as you can see the the website now is completely
spidered. And if we just check all the files that
we can find now you can see that we have some more
JavaScript files. And essentially what's happened
here is the entire site has been, has been
spidered. Okay, now we already did this with burp.
And the you know, you've you're probably really
bored of this right now. So what we're going to do
now is we need to, we need to start discovering
the hidden content, right. So let me just close
all of this up. There we are. Fantastic. Now,
let me just open that up. And let's go to Mattel
today. Oops, my bad Sorry about that, guys.
And we want to right click on Mattila day,
and you want to go to attack and you want to go
to first browse directory and children that's very
important. First browse directory will not display
everything, we'll also be looking at fuzzing,
but that's for later. Alright, so you want to make
sure you hit forced browse directory, just click
on that. And it's going to open up this tab here.
So you can see we are despite the tab open, which
you can close read if you're not using it, which
is also great. I really like the management of
zap, you then have output for your outputs alerts.
As you can see, you have some alerts here that
will alert you on some potential vulnerabilities.
So for example, APPLICATION ERROR, disclose,
you have some cookies, a noise GTP flag. So again,
awesome stuff there. We have to get requests,
all that good stuff, which is again focused on a
different type of attack. And as you can see, by
default, we've got the robots. txt here, which you
can analyze if you want to, by clicking and going
ahead and doing that. So you can copy the URL to
the browser. So again, copy the URL to clipboard,
alright, and if we just try and explore this,
let me just paste and go here. As you can see,
we're for some reason, we're not actually getting
robots to txt. Let me use the motility date. Till
today, or actually, you know what, let's not do
that right now, because I really want to stay
on topic here. So I'm just gonna go back into
that. Again, I always love going off topic,
fourth topic for some reason. Okay, so make sure
you click on motility and you want to right click
on it. And now Oh, sorry, we already did the
first browser, right click, go to attack and
first browse, directory and children. Alright,
now it's going to open up this tab here. And
it's going to, it's going to make you choose the
site. As you can see, you have your site IP here.
Now you need to select the default directory
list to it's going to use this list here, this
default list that comes already with zap. And now
it's going to try and use it in a sort of a brute
force way to try and detect the hidden files and
folders. And once it gets the result, it's going
to enumerate them. Okay, so now you want to right
click again on it, after you've selected the list
and hit attack. And you want to go to force browse
directory and children. And once you hit that,
it's going to start the process. Now again, this
is going to take a long, while not a long time,
depending on this the size of the website,
if the site is huge, then again, it's gonna
take a while. And as you can see, immediately
we're getting some submitted files. So let's,
let's wait for this call to complete. And I know
motility has some very, very interesting files
here that I'm sure will be happy to get. Alright,
so just let it go through this. As you can see,
you can check the progress as you're going here.
And again, the the if you look at the status code,
you can see 200 means the pages were found. So
you can just go ahead and look for things that
are irregular. And I'm sure we can find something
here that we haven't found before. Or you can
look at the at the file form the website directory
here. So um, Mattila day, let's see if we can find
something that is really, really interesting year.
So we have the includes we have the get index of
PHP, we get regressed, sorry for the index dot
o we have something interesting here we have a
notes folder. Aha, now we're talking now this
is where stuff gets really exciting. Alright,
so we have whoops, where'd it go? There we are.
So in notes, we have some very interesting files
in notes. So we have a get passwords. Now
what happens? What's this about? Alright,
so what if what what if we just open this URL
in the browser? Alright, so let me just try and
open that in Firefox, I just want to see what
it's going to be all about. So hopefully, it's
opened up in my browser. If it's not, I'll have to
copy the URL, probably because I haven't set any,
any default. Alright, so copy URLs to clipboard.
And let me just paste that in there, paste and go.
There we are Mattila day and passwords. Alright,
so you can see that this folder or this file was
hidden. And we have an interesting txt file here,
which again is quite scary to go we did open
Firefox. Well, don't doesn't look like we need
that instance. So getting back to the topic here,
for some reason, process unexpectedly closed
with. Alright, so that looks like we have a
Java error there. So let me just go back in over
here. So again, we found an accounts dot txt file,
what could that be? be caring. Let's click on
that. Oh boy. So again, we have accounts here.
And well, I'm pretty sure you will know what this
means. This is just bad practice from the website
developer, where he wrote notes. And essentially,
these are the accounts. Now let's see what else we
can find. Let's see accounts. Nothing interesting
in accounts, because we now have the account. So
that makes our brute force much easier. You then
have, let's see if we can find any passwords if
they were ever saved here. I'm pretty sure they
are not. But we can also look for some interesting
files here. That can be really interesting. Or you
can look at the sitemap if you want to. So let's
also copy that. Let's see if it gives us access to
the sitemap also very, very important stuff there.
Oh, yeah, so the sitemap, for some reason, we were
not able to process it. Alright, let's look for
some other files here. Let me just open up Mattila
day again. So we have the get images. Let's see if
we run the get images. Let's see what images we
can get. Again, I'm going pretty amateurish on
this. I'm just clicking on everything. But I'm
just trying to show you the amount of files that
you can find, as you can see, immediately, you
can find that the refresh button, you know all
the icons related to the website. You have the
I hack banner. Oh, yeah, hackers for charity,
man. So I'm talking about YouTube. Oh my god, what
an old logo that is the older BSP logo. Pretty
cool. Pretty cool. And yeah, so you get the idea.
So this is how you actually go through website
and find files that could contain you know, stuff
that is quite interesting, to be honest. So let's
see what else we can find. I'm just going to go
to one more resource here that we've found, oh,
we have to get register out. Now. That's what I'm
talking about copy URL to clipboard. It's actually
it's actually quite fun. This why bug bounty
hunting is? Oh, yeah. Now this is what I'm told
we can actually register. We can actually register
ourselves on the website. Now again, looking at
the website from here, it doesn't look like we
can. Can we even register on this website? Not
sure we can. For some reason, it's not actually
letting me scroll to the top. But hey, I don't
really know what's going on there. So let's see
if we, yeah, we can definitely log in render and
register. Sorry about that. We can register there.
So yes, it is the register. It does exist. So that
wasn't actually hidden. But it was hidden. It was
hidden to the women when we spidered the website.
So that means indeed, it was hidden, for obvious
reasons. Because the brute force for example,
if you find the login, which is again here,
and again, if this is hidden, you can imagine
the the damage that you can do so again, you can
log in from there. Set up database, whoo. Now,
that's interesting. For some reason, it's not
letting me copy. Alright, so looks like we got
set up database here. So yeah, we can Okay, I
do not want to manually edit the request. No,
I do not want to manually edit the request. For
some reason my keyboard is being pressed here.
While that's we admin, copy heroes to clipboard.
All right, sorry about that my spacebar was being
mashed on by my tablet in front of me. Right.
So let me just there we are on. So no PHP MySQL
errors, were resetting. So essentially reset the
database, and you can see the damage that this can
do. So again, that is some good stuff that you can
have fun with, when especially with Mattila day,
you can increase the security and find what other
files you can, you can find, you know, with zap,
again, zap is a fantastic alternative that you can
use. If you know if you're not ready to invest in
burp suite, that's totally fine. I used zap for
I think about three years, especially since 2014.
I think I used it in till about I think 2016 or
17. I'm not too sure. And it worked great for me,
I really enjoyed it. And I'm just getting back to
I'm just remembering all the tools used to work,
it was actually quite a user intuitive
interface. Because I just remember right
clicking means you can copy the URL, you
can inspect it, you can change the request,
you can attack all that good stuff. And you know,
it's sorted out really, really well. Alright,
and you can look at the requests here,
you can change them to whatever you want,
and then send them you can intercept them. So
it essentially does whatever but a suite does.
We're going to be looking at web application
firewalls, or waafs, as they're called. Now,
this may be a new term for you and do not worry.
This is now when we move into a more professional
level. And again, this is what I've been talking
about is most people out there or most documented
documentation out there won't cover the most
important industry standards. You know, now when
I'm talking about web application firewalls, what
I mean is, is these are the protection or these
are the mitigation procedures. put in place to
protect a web application from attacks, obviously
now as a penetration tester, or if you're
looking at it from a white hat, or a black hat
perspective, from wider perspective, it's always
important to have a web application firewall. And
I'll probably make another video showing you how
to set it up, it's really easy, and it's free,
and it will probably removed about 20% of attacks.
Okay, so that's if you're a white hat. Now,
if you're a black hat, and you're targeting, or
you're performing a penetration test legally on
a website or web application, we usually what
the employer will tell you is they'll give you
a scope of the project. And again, they might give
you the source code, etc, etc, you get the idea,
you have your white box, testing, black box
and gray box. But coming back to the firewall,
most of them will know that there is a firewall.
And that's because the person who set the website
up for them in terms of hosting, or the web
application for them, will in most cases,
on a professional level, have a web application
firewall. Now you might be a bit confused. And
you might be saying, Well, why is this important
when performing a penetration test? Well, this
is important because firstly, it's something that
most pen testers overlook. And if you know this,
you've got an ace up your sleeve. Alright, so
essentially, what's happening is if it's being
used, if a web application firewall is being
used, you obviously first need to detect it.
And I'm going to show you how to detect it in
this video using a special tool that I don't
think you've ever heard of. But it's also industry
standard. So this is a real secret, I don't know,
for some reason, it's not just, it's something
that just hasn't caught up yet. But hopefully,
after this video, you'll know about it. Alright,
so essentially, the purpose of a web application
firewall is it protects the web application, you
know, from a firewall point of view in the sense
that it blocks attacks, as one would expect them
to come. Now what does this mean for you? Well,
this means that you will need to, you will
need to manipulate any type of data that is
going to be encoded, alright. So what this
means is, if you're, if you're performing a
penetration test that involves you manipulating
data and sending it back to the web application,
then you need to encode it in a specific way to
bypass the firewall. Otherwise, it will be blocked
by the firewall. And I'm sure most of you have
actually done this before. If you're just amateur
penetration testers, and you've just begun, you'll
find that for some reason, your requests aren't
being processed. And that's because they've, there
is a firewall set up to prevent these malicious
requests from being processed. Okay, so again, web
application firewall is really, really important.
Now, looking at the tool we'll be using, the tool
has actually a very, very funny name you for some
of you might find it hilarious, it is called wolf
wolf. Now for those of you who have heard of it,
you pretty much already know how to detect a web
application firewall, but it's really very, very
simple. Alright, so just open up your terminal.
And what you want to do is you want to type in
wolf wolf. Alright, so this is how it is going
to be spelt. So it's worth Wolf with a tooth with
two zeros. And the syntax is pretty simple. If I
just hit enter, as you can see, we're forth a web
application firewall detection tool. Alright, so
credit go to the author, it's actually it's a tool
that's been there since the, I think almost the
last version of backtrack and the first version
of Kali. So again, quite an old tool, I when I say
old, I mean, you know, I mean that with respect,
given the fact that it's a really, really useful
and I've used it a lot because it saves you a lot
of time. And what I'm talking about is, so let's
say we want to scan a website, okay. In this case,
I have my WordPress server running here. And as
you can see, it's the site is being hosted on
190 2.1 68 point 1.11. Alright, so I have that IP
opened up in my browser. And as you can see, it's
a WordPress site. And this site is vulnerable.
And this is what we're going to be performing
later on the penetration tests on. But for now, we
want to find out whether it has a firewall. Now by
default, I know it doesn't have a firewall. But
let's see what we're for Fidelis, alright, so the
syntax is very simple. As you can see, you just
type in wolf Wolf, and you enter your URL or your
URL, so you can enter as many as you like. Okay,
so I'll give you an example of how to go about it,
make sure you enter your HTTP or HTTPS protocol.
And we just, let's try that out. So Wolf, Wolf,
and we specify our protocol HTTP in this case, and
the IP address 190 2.1 68 point 1.11. All right,
now in this case, I'm pretty sure that it
won't detect any web application firewall.
So let me just hit Enter. And as you can see,
no web application firewall detected by the
generic detection. Alright, now this is very,
very advanced. And this tool is an industry
standard. And if it does tell you that there is
no web application firewall, then by all means,
I can guarantee that it will it does not have
a firewall. Now let's look at one of my sites
that I currently own. It's a site that I use. It's
actually My web development company that obviously
we use for web development now I've predicted this
site with a web application firewall provided by
CloudFlare. Now, for those of you who are web
developers, and when you're performing your
hosting, you know that using CloudFlare is awesome
because it allows you to optimize your site for
speed. It allows you to purchase assets and make
your site faster, protected, and again, protected
from DDoS attacks, etc, etc, all the good stuff.
So let's see if it will actually detect this. So
I'm going to type in wolf wolf. I know that name
is really, really funny. The protocol is HTTPS,
https like so and I'm going to specify the
site which is Elgon studios.com. Alright,
Elgon studios.com. And if I enter, as you can
see, it's going to start checking the site, give
it a few seconds, it shouldn't take any much. You
know, a lot of time, and as you can see the site,
Elgon studios.com is behind CloudFlare. Right now,
what this means is that most of the most of the
attacks that involve manipulation of data will
be in some way blocked. And you know, you won't
get your response back the way you wanted it. And
the render wouldn't be the same. Right now. Again,
as you can see, it detected that it is behind
a web application firewall. Now the next step
is how to encode these, how to encode encode your
your requests that you're going to be sending to
the web application. And that's what we'll be
looking at as we increase the security level,
using the the dam vulnerable web application.
Alright, so I thought, this is something that
I really need to share with you, again, it's
going to really help you. And I promise you, this
is something that, you know, if you go for a job
interview, or you're performing a penetration test
for a company, this is something that most of the
network or systems administrators are very keen
on, they want to know whether you really know your
stuff, and whether you're really up to date with
how to detect, first of all, because information
gathering is really important. And as you can see,
this tool is fantastic. And once you know there's
a firewall, you then have a better idea of how to
target and you won't be wasting time. Again,
that's something that most of the amateurs or
beginners do. They waste a lot of time trying
different commands that they've seen, but they
find the date and they see that it doesn't work.
And they're like, how is this possible? Am I doing
something wrong? The truth is, the web application
is probably well protected. So again, you know,
do not use this for any malicious purposes. Again,
this is simply an information gathering tool.
I'm going to be showing you how to use der Buster
to discover directories and files on a website or
a web application. You might be asking yourself,
what is der Buster? Or if you haven't heard of
der buster, let me explain it to you. Alright,
so the airburst is essentially a tool that was
developed by OS, the open web application security
project, and essentially uses a brute forcing to
find commonly used directories and file names
on servers. Alright, so this tool is extremely
useful for those of you who are doing CTF, for
those of you who are bug bounty hunters, because
essentially, it allows you to understand the
structure of a web web application or a website in
terms of the files and directories and how they're
structured. Alright, so why is this important?
Well, this is important because this will help us
understand how we can attack a site or what type
of attack vectors we can, we can we can find, you
know, so for example, if I the web application,
and I'm going to demonstrate that right now, and
I scanned it with the bust, and we found some
hidden directories and hidden files, we can use
these as attack vectors. Alright, so as I said,
it also allows you to find hidden directories or
files that are hidden from the public. So this
can also lead you to, to finding additional
resources that could have been hidden away
by the devs that like for example, admin pages,
etc, etc. Alright, so how does it work? Well,
really simply, once you start up there, Buster,
and again, as I mentioned, it uses brute forcing
so I'll explain where wordless come into play.
So you open it up and you select the URL of the
web application or the website and you specify
the port The port is is the is definitely going
to be HTTP sewed a the a port 80 or Port 443. And
then you select the word list now, in this case,
Cali annex already has a dub dub Buster word list
that that are designed, it has three of them that
are designed for different types of scenarios.
And I'll explain them as we move along. All right,
and essentially how it works is once you start
the brute force attack, it will send HTTP GET
requests, and it will wait for the response from
the server or the web, the web application. If
it gets a 200 response. That means that yes, that
directory exists. Alright, if it gets if it gets a
bad response, meaning like 400 or four or three,
meaning no access, then it'll it will it will
know that that directory of file doesn't exist. So
it's essentially testing directories on the server
against This, this word list. So it will check,
for example, is there a temp folder, if it sends
a temp request to the server, it gets a response,
a positive response, then it knows it's there,
and then it will enumerate them. Alright, so let's
start off really, really simply. So I'm on Cali
the next, I have the OS, broken web application,
right here. And I'm going to be demonstrating two
scenarios. So you can see I'm running that
here. And that has a lot of vulnerable web
applications. But the whole idea is to demonstrate
how directories can be found. Alright, and why
this is extremely important, especially for a
web application penetration tester. Alright, so
I'm gonna pull up Firefox. And as you can see, you
have the open web application project right here,
the OS B web, as they call it, and it has plenty
of ways of me testing this. But what if I was to
just test the entire server? Alright, so this is
a web server. What if I was to test the entire web
so well, I'm guessing that there going to be a lot
of files and directories. So what we can do is,
we can start off with a perfect example of how
this will work is let's say you're targeting a
WordPress site. So I'm going to open up the broken
WordPress. Now, of course, this is an very old
one, and we're not really exploiting anything. But
by using this example, it will let us understand
how we can enumerate the different directories and
folders, you know, on this WordPress installation,
or if you are target targeting a WordPress
site, this is the way you do it. So I'm going
to copy the URL with the with the directory right
here. So it we know it's in the WordPress folder,
because that is the root directory of the of
the web server and we're selecting the WordPress
installation. But for the website, you will
select the URL. Alright. And that's for the port,
we know that this is the default HTTP port, which
means it's Port 80. Alright, so I have doorbuster.
Right here, if you can't find it, just you can use
the start menu and type in der buster, it's going
to be like so just this click on it, and give it a
few seconds to start up. So again, it was designed
by the OS team. So it works really, really well.
And again, this is something that I'm sure if you
if you are a web application penetration tester,
or you do do the CTF challenges, then you will,
you'll know that use this tool a lot. Alright, so
we in here, we have the target URL, and that will
we will paste it Alright, so we can paste it right
here. So Ctrl V, and that is the URL. Now in the
work method, if you want to, if you want the scan
to be faster, you can use the GET requests, but
what we can do is auto switch them from the head
and get and that will give us a more robust or a
more accurate response rate. Alright, so in terms
of the number of days, this is how fast you want,
you want the scan or the brute force to be, so the
faster the better depending on your hardware. And
of course, you don't want to overload the server,
so I'm just going to go hit click on Go faster,
that's probably works the best for me. But if you
wanted to run faster, then that means it's gonna,
it's gonna have multiple requests and threads
being sent from your computer. Alright,
so I like keeping it at just 200 threads, which
is go faster. And because I'm testing my own web
server, I can, you know, I can pretty much
increase it to whatever I want. So usually,
if you're talking about a bigger server or a
bigger web application, then it doesn't really
matter how many requests or many threads you use,
it will not really affect the performance of the
web server. But if I was to run it at maybe a
maximum speed, you'd see that the web server
would be lagging out, you know, out of the amount
of requests that are being sent. Because you know,
you have to understand it from a fundamental point
of view, we are requesting different web pages,
and the server has to process them. So if the if
the if the server is not running on on, you know,
good resources, like it's running on one gigabyte
of RAM, it's very easy to make it lag out,
and to actually cause some sort of a denial of
service just because of the amount of requests.
But in this case, we are performing it you
know, with with an ethical perspective. So now,
you want to select a list based brute force or you
can use a pure brute force. But I don't recommend
that that doesn't really work. And you now need to
select your word list your doorbuster word list.
Now by default on Kali Linux and on paradise,
these are found in the user share folder on the
under word list. And you can find the doorbuster
word list right there. So I'm going to show you
that right now. So I'm going to browse, I'm going
to go to my root and I'm going to go into user
and I'm going to go into share. And let's go into
Word Lists here. Let's see if I can find it. It's
obviously with a W. Where it Where is it? Let's
see. Let's see. Let's see where is wordless story
if I can see this. Yeah, there we are. Sorry about
that. wordlist and you now want to go into der
buster. Alright, so there is going to be a folder
called der buster. And now you might be a little
bit confused. Well, really, you don't need to need
me to be confused. That's why I'm here. So as a
beginner you might be wondering like which one
is better. Now as an advanced penetration test,
I know which one is the best in Most cases,
it's going to be the medium the directory list
2.3 medium dot txt. Now, if you're scanning a very
small web application that that's not that really
complex, like a simple HTML site, you know, HTML,
CSS, whatever you want to call it, then I would
recommend the smaller one. But if you're scanning
a big site, like a WordPress installation,
or a Joomla installation, then you should use the
medium one, this will work 99% of the time unless
your your, your requests are being blocked by
either a web application firewall or by the,
the host. So I'm just going to select list.
Alright. And now in terms of these other options,
you can see it's, it's going to essentially
brute force brute force the directories,
the files, it's going to be recursive, which is
great. And the directory, you must specify the
directory if it is if you are trying to perform
a scan that is directory sensitive. Alright,
and standard start point, just leave it like
that. And you now want to hit start. Alright,
so once you start is going to start brute forcing
the web server against, it's going to start
sending the request. And if it gets the responses,
the positive responses is going to, it's going to
understand that yes, that directory does exist.
Now you can see we have a response that is being
sent here. And it's going to tell tell you that
it is unable to determine a consistent failed
response, which means some directories and files
are being you're getting a negative or you're
getting a no access response, meaning that that
directory doesn't exist. So what you can do is
just hit Cancel to these ones in it Yes. And it's
going to continue scanning the other ones. Now of
course down here you can see since it's performing
a brute force, you can look at the current speed,
which varies dependent on the amount of
directories, the average speed, and it will
tell you the total amount of requests done out of
the amount that could be done depending on on the
word list that you have selected. And finally, you
have the time to finish. Now, of course, this will
vary depending on a lot of factors. But mostly
it depends on the speed of the scan that you've
selected, and the and the word list. So you have
your scan information here, it's going to tell you
what folders and files it's testing. And in here,
you can see the results in terms of directories
and files that it was able to find. And in the
results, this is going to give you the directory
structure as to how files and folders are being
structured on the web application. Now by default,
right now, you can see the amount of the
files and folders that it has found are,
for example, the WordPress register dot php.
So if we open that, if you right click on it,
you can open it in the URL, or you can view
the response that it gave. And you can copy it,
you understand you get the basic functionality
here. And then you can open it in your browser.
So again, you see that we are finding files that
we otherwise wouldn't have known existed. Now,
of course, for a default WordPress installation,
you would have guessed that this does exist. But
remember, most people are for volken, for most
other installations on configured figurations,
this can be a great way of finding files and
folders that you didn't know existed. And again,
discovering them is very, very important. And
this can give you different attack vectors. So
for example, if I went to the admin dot php, and
it forced me to log in, that might be a good place
to start brute forcing, if I had credentials, if
not, you can choose Select another attack vector.
So let me just move back here you can see we have
the register page here, which we just clicked on.
Let's look at the WordPress login dot php. So
I'm gonna open that up in the browser. Now you
can see the server is not responding. And that's
another point that I wanted to point out. If you
want to be as you know, right now we are being
as promiscuous as possible. Because we it's
not really a web application that is delivering
service to other people. But because it's hosted
on my local area network. So in this case, you
can do a performing a type of denial of service.
And that's because the server is located very,
very minimal resources to this virtual machine.
So that's why it's kind of lagging out. Alright,
so that's something to take into consideration.
Now if I was to, to pause the attack, like so if I
was to just pause it, remember, you can pause it,
and you can stop it. And let me just go back
here. And let's see if we can reload these pages,
they should be able to, to be reloaded quick
enough. Let me let me just load that up. And
we can close this one. Let's see if the WordPress
register page does open up. If this virtual, yeah,
there we are. So you can see even though this
is a very old WordPress installation, that we
were causing it to lag out. So always keep that in
mind that the amount of threads that you say can
affect the performance of the website of or of the
web application and you don't want to cause any
any impact to customers if you're performing the
test on a real world working web application or
website. Alright, just something you might want to
take into consideration. So we're going to resume
it and of course I'm not going to expect to find
anything we add here. Although this WordPress
installation is designed to be vulnerable.
So you can also change the number of threads
running right here. So if I wanted to run, you
know, maybe on 10 threads, which is quite slow,
that means you will get, the enumeration process
will take longer. So it's all about balancing your
resources and understanding what you're trying
to look for. And of course, this can be a very,
very useful tool. When doing bug bounties, or,
or CTF for that matter, especially hack the box,
we are going to be looking at something that is
extremely important and something that should be
understood completely, and that is cross site
scripting. Alright, now before we get started,
I'm just going to explain what we're going to
be looking at explain what we're going to be
looking at in this video, we're going to start
off with explaining what cross site scripting is,
I'm going to be showing you the environment
that we'll be using for testing any of these,
any of these attacks just because they allow
us to illustrate or they allow me to explain
how everything works, because that's the most
important thing for me is that you understand
what you're you're listening to, and you have a
good representation of what's going on. Alright,
so I'll be explaining stored. I'll be explaining
the reflected stored and Dom cross site scripting.
Alright, so let's get started with me explaining
what environment I'm currently running. So you
can see that I'm running Kali Linux right now.
But I am going to be using the OS broken web
applications project. So I'll have this in
the description section, it is essentially
a virtual machine, that you can easily just run
on VirtualBox or VMware. I'm currently running
it here. As you can see, I just got the local
IP, it's 190 2.1 68 point 1.111. All right, so
I have that running. And I'm running this on Kali
Linux, and I already have opened up the URL in my
browser. So you can see from here, I've opened
up v whap. And I've opened up webgoat, because
that's what I'm going to be using to explain each
of these cross site scripting attacks. So if I
was to do that false to just open up 190 2.1 68
point 1.11, yours could be different, it should
be different. Depending on your IP configuration,
and subnet, then it'll take you to the OS, b,
w A, or the OS broken web applications project.
The latest version, as of recording this video
is version 1.2. So we will be using webgoat and B
web, or the broken web application project for for
this demonstration. So the default credentials for
webgoat are going to be guest for the username and
guest for the password. And for B whap. It should
give you the prompt right over there. I think it's
going to be bug app or something like that. But
irregardless, it will tell you what it is. All
right. So make sure you open that up, and you have
that all set up. So I've logged in to be web and
I have a web goat started up right here. Alright,
so let me close that up. And we are ready to go.
Now before we even move on into performing these
attacks, it's very important to understand what's
going on here with with cross site scripting,
what it is how it works. And what are you exactly
taking advantage of right now, this is where a lot
of people make mistakes. And if you want to be a
successful web application penetration tester, you
need to understand, you know, from a fundamental
level, what's going on here. Alright, so let's
get started. What is cross site scripting? Well,
simply put it is the process of injecting a script
into a into the parameter in a URL to attack
a user of the site or to potentially attack the
server side of the website or the web application,
right? So essentially, is the inject the
injection of a script into the parameter of
a URL. All right, that's essentially what it is.
Now, of course, this may be quite confusing, but
don't worry, I'll explain what's going on here. So
let's start off with with, first of all explaining
the three types of cross site scripting. All
right, the first one is reflected and then
we have stored and Dom. So with reflected what's
happening here is the data is inputted and then,
you know, reflected directly back back on the
screen. So I'll explain this in a second. Alright,
so if we are to look at this from a fundamental
perspective, I'll show you how to access this,
you know how to navigate the view up. Just give
me a second, let me explain what's going on. So
essentially, what's happening with reflected cross
site scripting is that the input is going to be
stored in the parameter of the URL. All right,
and I'll explain how this differs with each type
of attack. Because many of you will point out and
say, well, it's not only to do with parameters,
and don't worry, I'll explain all of this.
Alright, so we can essentially manipulate the the
parameter of the URL, so that we can essentially
run a script. Now what type of script we can run a
malicious script that is based on in JavaScript,
and I'll explain that right now. So you can see
with our portal, you don't want to touch anything
here, you can set the security level. But for now,
I recommend setting it to lope. Not that that's
going to hurt anyone's ego. Because remember,
you have to be humbled to begin, and you need to
understand what's going on first. So we will open
up the Jews, the bugs section here, and we want
to go down into cross site scripting. And we want
to go into reflected which essentially deals with
the get the get request. So we're going to start
off with that. And this will really make you
understand what's going on here. So if I click
on that, and I just hit hack. Alright, so now it's
going to give us a prompt here. And you might be
asking, Well, what what do you mean, what exactly
is going on, if I was to not enter any details
into the, you know, into these fields, right
here. So for example, you can see I just had a
suggestion there, that's because I was testing it
out. But if I was to hit go, you can see that in
the URL, we do have the input here. So you can see
the values can be edited directly into the form.
So you can see first name has no value. And then
we have the last name, which again has no value,
and you can see that it is submitting a form.
So what we can do is run some JavaScript code
in here. And the most common way of explaining
what's going on here, of course, not running a
very malicious code right now, it's essentially
explaining and demonstrating that it does work is
I can run a piece of code here. Now, of course,
when you put this into a practical perspective,
many sites are going to filter the content that
you can enter in these fields, all these forms,
and will essentially will not allow you to
run JavaScript code and you know, obviously,
to protect, protect the site from these type of
attacks. But what you can do is encapsulated to
encode it in a different type of language.
Or, as I said, I'll show y'all everything,
or how all of this works. So this right, right
now, being the current security level, as low,
we are a lot a lot essentially encode, it will
not verify or validate what we're entering in
here what input is being given. So if we were
to type in a script here, so we can say script,
and you can see the recommendation there script,
that's mine. So if I was to type in alert, and
this is JavaScript, so I'm pretty, I'm pretty sure
you can you know what's going on. So we can say,
Hello world. This is an example of reflected
accesses, or cross site scripting, and we can
close that operate now. And then we need to close
the script. So we can do that in the next field or
the next parameter. Most people like doing it from
the start. But this is just to show you how robust
this can be. So I type in I close the script and
hit go. And as you can see, it gives us the alert,
which is what we and we which is what we used
as a form of, of me showing you that it does
work and it will be processed, the input will be
processed and will be sent back to you, you being
the client. And we can just hit OK. And that was
an example of reflected excess cross cross site
scripting, using the get method. Now of course
we can, I can replicate this many, many times
using the other types of cross site scripting, for
example, with the post, etc, etc. We'll be looking
at all of that. But for now we need to understand
what's going on here. Now next, we need to look
at stored cross site scripting, this is probably
my favorite because of the potential that it does
have. Alright, so let's go into the juicy bug menu
here. And we want to go into cross site scripting,
and we want to go we want to go for the blog,
cross site scripting stored cross site scripting,
and we're gonna select blog, and I'll
explain why in a second. Alright, so first,
let me explain what stored cross site scripting
is. So essentially, with this with the cross site
scripting attacks, more specifically, these stored
attacks, essentially, what's happening is you're
attacking the input. And you're essentially
attacking the input that is to be stored or
you're attacking the data, or, essentially, I'll
explain this really simply, so you're attacking
the input that is to be stored on a database. So
what you're doing is you're essentially injecting
malicious code that will be saved into a database,
or that is going to be saved by the server,
or the web application server. And then you can
definitely you since it's being stored, you can
access it later on or other users can access it.
And for example, if it's running malicious code,
it can trigger different things like opening
the webcam of a user stealing different type of
information. I'm not going to go into what you can
do with it, but you can really do a lot of stuff,
a lot of malicious stuff with code. Alright, so
let me explain what's going on here. So with this
stored, cross site scripting, you can essentially
inject malicious code into the database again,
that then that when accessed runs this
malicious code. Alright, so if you can see
this is an example of a blog. Let me explain what
I mean the best places to implement stored cross
site scripting is in places like means, you know
forums. And again, as you can see write your blog
in the form of comments that you know, or pages
that can be accessed later, or data that is being
stored in directly into the database, any database
for that matter as long as it's being stored,
okay, so we can type in something like hello.
And we can submit that to the database. And
you can see it's getting stored. And you have
the different tables, you have the the number,
the owner, the date and the entry. So now we can
also run a script in here. Alright, so what if we
were to enter Java scripts, and again, this data,
given our security level is any of the data that
we're entering is not being validated. So you
can essentially enter it raw. Now in reality,
if you go and try and enter a script in the
native will not be accepted, because, again,
they're protecting their site against that.
That's one way of mitigation, very basic,
I'm sure you know what I'm talking about. Alright,
so enough of me rambling on. So if we are doing
enter the same script we entered, we are to say
script. And we then say, alert, for example,
we can you can use any type of JavaScript code
you want here, and you can experiment, you know,
you these web applications are there for you to
experiment and test your skills out. So first
to say, Hello world. This is stored out stored
cross site scripting, and we just close that up
there. And of course, we have to close the script,
because we know that that will not execute if we
do not code it correctly. Okay, so now we can we
can add that. And if I was to just hit submit,
right, now, you can see that it's going to store
and with that being the latest blog post, you can
see it's going to tell you, it's going to execute
the script. And it's going to say hello world.
This is stored cross site scripting. So an example
of a blog, if you're to post this on a page or a,
you know, to make a blog post and inject this
script in, anyone opens that page will essentially
run that malicious code. And whatever that code
does, can then furthermore, you know, cause damage
to the user or to the server depending on what you
want it to do. So it's all dependent on what the
attacker is to do. Remember what I told you in
the first video of this series, it's all about
your mindset, and your your your willingness to
break things and to find out what does and doesn't
work. Okay, so that was an example of stored
cross site scripting. And as I've mentioned,
the most important thing to understand is this in
this scenario, the data is not being validated if
it is being validated. And I'll show you that in
a second. Or probably in the next set of videos,
we'll increase the security level, and I'll show
you how to get you know past this, you can see
how things change as you move along in terms of
security levels. So I was going to use the V whap.
This my first time using it. So I had to get a
bit of an introduction through the documentation.
And I realize they don't have dumb cross site
scripting. So I that's why I had to use webgoat.
They're the only ones I know who actually allow us
to run it. So as zoomed in right now, by the way,
the credentials are guests for the username
and guest for the password. So essentially,
I went through cross site scripting, and again,
they didn't have the DOM in here, all they were
focusing on is stored and again, reflected. So I
found it to be in the eye x or Ajax or whatever
you want to call it. And we have the the DOM
based cross site scripting, let me explain why
it's in. This is based in Ajax security. This
is because Dom cross site scripting focuses on
the client side. So any data or input that is
entered, whether it be a malicious code, etc,
etc, is going to be processed by the client, not
the server. So any of the attacks will be based,
of course, on the client. Now, let me explain
what I mean. If I am to run remember, JavaScript,
server side, client side i x, for example.
So if I am to run, for example, a JavaScript
code in this entry here, so script, and again, I
type in alert, just being the example and I say,
Hello, let's keep that simple. And I close the
script here, you can see that we will probably
not be left with anything will not get any result.
That's because it's being processed by the client,
not by the server. So no, no result or no data
will be reflected back to us. If it was, you know,
if it was reflected cross site, scripting it,
the server processes it, and then is reflected
back to the client. So if I was to submit here,
you can see that nothing happens here. And that
it is going to be taken as code. Now what if
we were to enter or use a language that that
a client can understand? So let's say we want
to say, let's see, HTML, whatever to use HTML,
so I can say in here, IMG, for example, that's a
very This is the way we learned it. So IMG See,
and we don't have an image source. So we can leave
that like that. And then we can use the on error,
in case we get an error of image which we will get
because the image has no source on error, we can
say that is going to be, that is going to be equal
to alert. And then the alert we can input in here,
we can say, Hello, whoops, hello world. And we
can close that up. And once we have closed it,
you can see that we can, we can close that there.
And there you are. So it is great to be processed
by the client, and you get the dialog box or the
alert with the message Hello world. So you can
see that with Dom based cross site scripting, it
is all being processed all the input, whether it
be malicious or not, is being processed by the
client. And Ei x is one of the largest languages
that can be used. So you can also incorporate
a x if you wanted to test it out. Remember,
it's all about experimentation and understanding,
I hope that you're you've got an understanding of
what cross site scripting is, how it can be
used to manipulate data, whether it be on
the client side on the database, and how you
can easily just transfer data with you know,
bad security in place. Of course, this is
the these attacks will be a very uncommon
now. But again, this was focused on more
on an explanation point of view. We're
going to be looking at cross site request forgery,
or CSRF. Now, this is an extremely important topic
and a big one that I cover it correctly. So for
the purpose of this video, I've set up a very
unique environment that in at least in my opinion,
will demonstrate how to utilize or how to perform
this attack. Alright, now I'm just going to give
you a brief overview of the environment that
I have no, of course, you can see I have a few
files open here. Don't worry about them right now,
just just remember that we'll be using them later
on. And I'll be using them really, really well to
explain what's going on here. So you can see as my
target or as my vulnerable system I'm going to be
using on my vulnerable web application, I should
say, I'm going to be using the OWASP juice shop
now. Not actually no one actually recommended this
to me. But I remember that I performed this during
a CTF challenge that I went to earlier, I think
late last year. I'm not too sure exactly when
but the whole process was involved in exploiting
this web application. Alright, and in my opinion,
this really outlined or really showed of how
to perform all of these various web application
attacks. In this case, we're going to be
focusing on cross site request forgery. Alright,
so I have the juice shop running it's, it's based
on a node.js. And it's running on my local host.
Let me just show you that right now. There we
are. So I haven't logged in or done anything
yet. And that's because I'm going to do that with
you. So I've set it up, it's running on my local
host. Let's get started with this really, really
simple but sometimes complicated topic. Alright,
so cross site request forgery CSRF. Now from
the name, you can already tell that it's split
into two into two sections, you have your cross
site, and your request forgery. So from that,
we can get a basic example of what's going on
here. We have cross site scripting, and we are
going to be forging requests or we are going to be
manipulating requests. Hmm, interesting. So we are
we are kind of understanding what's going on here.
Now the technical explanation for what CSRF is,
is it is an attack that forces an end user to
executed unwanted actions on a web application
in which they're currently authenticated. Alright,
so let me put that really, really simply, right,
it's an attack that will force an end user to
execute unwanted actions on the web, on a web
application, these actions can be anything, but in
this case, we're going to be looking at changing
the password. And they have to be currently
authenticated to that web application, which means
they have to be logged in to that web application
for this to work. Because if they're logged out,
then you get the idea. It really doesn't help or
it doesn't work. Alright, so we use cross site
scripting, in this case to perform the request
forgery, and to get either desired or undesired
results. In our case, we're going to be looking
at how to to change the password of any user
that's logged in to the to this web application.
And how will we How will we be doing that? Well,
we are going to be using CSRF. But the first
thing you need to understand is how an HTML form
works. Alright, and this is very important because
first of all, a client will request a page from a
server. Alright, the server will then respond and
give the the client the HTML form. The client will
then send back the form with the data back to the
server server will then authenticate and authorize
the user and then will will perform the requested
action. And based on the request and the response,
we are able to forge or to change the request
and get a desired response if you're looking at
it from an attackers perspective. Alright, so,
the the way CRS CS CSRF works sorry about that
is the attacker will manipulate the victim into
submitting the attackers form data to the victims
web server, essentially, essentially performing
these these requests in the in our case, as I've
mentioned, it will allow us to change the password
of any user on this web application, in this case,
the OWASP juice shop web application. Alright,
so now you might be asking, Well, if I'm a bug
bounty hunter, I'm practicing to become a bug
bounty hunter. How do I go about finding this
vulnerability? Well, that's a very good question.
And that is the question you should be asking
yourself when performing any penetration test.
Now, coming back to my environment, I'm running
burp suite, the Community Edition, you you will
just need the Community Edition for this one,
we're not performing any advanced techniques
here, because we're essentially just changing,
we're just going to be changing the request to get
our desired responses. But once we move on to the
advanced stuff, I'll then be using OS zap for
our attacks. Alright, so keeping things really,
really simple, we, the way to look for these
vulnerabilities is to target the login pages,
which we have right here, we then need to, we
can then create the account and log in. And
then finally, we will be creating our own our
own script to perform the cross site scripting.
And that will allow us to submit the data or
if we send the URL to another user of this
web application who is currently authenticated,
it will allow the it will allow us to make them
change their password, and then we can log into
their account. Alright, so this vulnerability
is very common on sites with accounts, you know,
sites that have emails of passwords. And as you
probably would have guessed, there are a lot
of sites that utilize this functionality. But
remember, most of the sites out there will be
protected from this vulnerability. So it's up
to you to find these vulnerabilities. Alright, so
as I've mentioned, we will be using OWASP juice
shop as our target. And the reason is, is because
it will explain what I want to explain really,
really well. Alright, and we'll be using the burp
suite Community Edition. Now, as you can see,
I'm currently running the burp proxy, I'm not
intercepting any traffic, if I open up burp suite,
I'm not intercepting any traffic. If I go to
the proxy, and intercept, I'm not intercepting
anything. So it's currently just I'm just going
through the burp proxy and all the traffic and
data is being logged through the proxy. So when
it comes down to this little data that I've
saved here, I've already created an account.
The reason I've done that is to save time,
because I don't want to explain everything about
it. So I've created, I've created a user with the
email of test@test.com and a password of password.
So really simple. Again, there's nothing really
complicated here. And if you want if you're
wondering what exactly does this mean? Well,
this is a security question with the answer.
So the question was, what's my favorite pet,
and I wrote in dog. So hopefully, that doesn't
scare you into thinking that I've gone completely
crazy. And then in here we have the scripts that
we'll be using, or will be utilizing to perform
the CSRF are on the site, I'll get to this in
a second. We don't need that right now. So if
I want to log in, I know that the email is
test@test.com. And the password is password.
Alright, so let me do that right now we need
to authenticate. So let me log in, like so. And
I'm going to hit test@test.com. Alright, and I'm
going to write the password, which is password,
and I'm going to log in. Alright, and I'm don't
want to save the password. And there you also
have logged in now. Now as I said, this is very
this vulnerability works really, really well when
you're talking about changing passwords, because
as you can probably guess, an attacker would would
be looking to exploit this functionality because
imagine, if we were able to send a request a get
request to our target with the URL encoded URL.
Of course, we can also use link shorteners,
if we wanted to, to do that. And essentially,
if they authenticated, it will allow us to make
them change their password simply by clicking
on the link, changing their password to whatever
we specify. Alright, so how do we do this? Well,
the first thing we need to do is we need to look
at how we get requests are being sent. And we can
do that using burp. So we're just going to change
our password. So current password is password.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to change
my password into password. Oops, sorry, pass word
123. And I'm going to repeat it so fast word 123.
And I'm going to hit Alright, so the password was
successfully changed. Okay, now let's look at how
this was processed in burp, or how the request was
sent in burp. So I'm going to go into burp proxy
and HTTP history. And I'm going to go all the way
to the bottom. And as you can see, we have the get
request right over here. Okay, so the get request
is very interesting. You can see we have the get
request, and it's targeting the the following URL.
And these are the parameters. So change password,
the current password is password, new password
123. And we've repeated it. Alright. So now let
us perform the forgery here. So I'm going
to send this in to the repeater. Alright,
so I'm going to click on repeater. And in here, we
can manipulate the request and see what responses
we get. All right, in case you, you did not know
about that. But again, let's start off really,
really simply. So we are going to be working
with the raw request. We don't want to work
with individual parameters, although you could
change it, but we are going to be manipulating
the request entirely so that it performs what we
want to do. Alright, so what we can do first is
we can test so let's change what if we were to
change the current password to something like,
let's see test, let's change it to test and
then we hit go, you can see that the response
we get is a is a 401 error, which means we are an
authorized to make that and it will give you the
message right here. The current password is not
correct. All right, that's good. That is good from
a web application perspective, which means that
this web application is performing validation.
And it's not going to allow us to know to just go
in and start manipulating any requests and making
changes. So from a security perspective, the web
application is doing really, really well. Alright,
what if I was to change the new password? Let
me change this back to password to the current
password, which is what we said and change the
new password to password pass 123. All right,
and I hit go. Again, we get another error. Again,
the 401 unauthorized error telling us that the new
and repeated password do not match. So yes, the
current password is correct. And the only thing
that we're getting an error is the new password
and the repeated password are not correct. So
interesting. What if we want to change the
password into password 123. And we can repeat that
again. So we want to confirm this. So password
123 actually hold on. So I'm going to say password
123. And now let's see what this tells us. This
should verify it. But let's see if this works.
So you can see yes, that does work. And we know
that this works, because that's what we did that
was the original request. But what if we do not
know the current password of the user? Remember,
we're going to be targeting other users of this
web application. So what if we get rid of and this
is very, very, this is the way penetration testers
go about it. What if we get rid of stuff? So what
if we get rid of the current password? Alright,
and now essentially, they get his targeting Change
Password with the question mark here, essentially
requesting and we're only entering the fields or
parameters new. And repeat what if we do that
and we change them to password 123 I mean,
pass 123 and pass 123. Let go. You can see yes,
it does work, we get the 200, the 200 response,
which means everything was processed correctly.
And we were able to get a password that looks
to be hash, that looks to be hashed. And we got
the email that we used. So yes, we do know that
it is working. Alright, so we know that we know
that this worked. But we need to confirm that
this has worked. So we can do this by going back
into our web application. And we can log out and
we can try and log in again. So log in with our
new password. So we're gonna say test@test.com,
and our new password was passed 123. Remember, we
changed it earlier. But again, I was demonstrating
that we if we are to send this to our target, we
need to specify to make sure that it will work
without any pre required information like their
current password. So I've manipulated the request
there. So let's hit log in. And voila, you can see
it does work. Excellent. All right. So this is a
fantastic example of so also CSRF can be utilized
or how it can be how you can find vulnerabilities
for it. Alright, so this can allow us to change
or update anyone's password. anyone's accounts
password that are currently logged into this web
application. Alright, so now what we what we need
to do well, we can we can log in. As we've already
seen, we can log in and once you've logged in,
we can we can test to see if cross site scripting
does work. And then of course utilizing it
throughout the web application is very important.
So We can run a simple cross site script attack to
see if it will work on the search bar right here.
So I'm going to type in script. And a simple one.
So alert, just to test whether it works. And
in the alert, we can say, Hello, just something
stupid hello world, you know, that's an I can't
even type man Come on world. And we've typed in
the alert. And we can finally close the script
here. Script like so. And let's hit search.
And voila, we can see that indeed, cross site
scripting work works, which means we can insert,
we can insert our GET request inside a script and
use a cross site scripting to perform the CSRF.
And now you can see them conjoining together,
cross site scripting with request forgery. Okay,
so we now need to create our custom script
that will allow us to utilize the attack.
And we will be using XML and HTTP. Now, you
might have seen this script right over here,
let me just minimize this and open up leafpad, you
might have seen this script that I created. Now
you can find many of these CSRS scripts are online
that utilize different languages. In my case,
I find the one that works the best is the
is the one that works with x XML and HTTP
and contains the get request in here. Okay, now,
you can see that the get request requires the URL
in which we submit the the parameters without the
current password. So we need to go back into burp.
And it needs to go back into proxy HTTP. Sorry
about that HTTP, we look to change the password.
So if we go back into, sorry, the repeater. And
if we look at this now, we can see that the URL
is right over here. So that's the get request. So
if we copy this localhost, obviously, and we are
not using any current password field, so if we
can do that, really, really simply, you can see
how this can be utilized really, really well. So
what we need to do now is understand how the URL
will be format. And of course, the web application
is going to encode it, and I'll get to that in a
second. So we need to copy this URL right here.
So I'm just going to copy the URL. And we can
edit our our script. So HTTPS, and we paste it in
inside the URL, you can copy this script if you
want to. Let's take a look at whether this script
is formatted correctly. So get HTTP new, that's
not the way we want it. Let me get rid of the
pre pre determined HTTP there. So HTTP localhost,
it's hosted on my localhost with the Port 3000
node, an OJS standard. And the we want to change
the password, the new password is past 123 and
repeat his past 123, you can change that to
whatever you want, if you want to, you know, play
around with the script. But in my case, I don't
want to do any of that. So this is the script. So
what we can do is we can copy this now. And we can
run this in the search bar. And that should, in
theory, and in practice, give us our first CSRF
attack on the site. So I'm going to paste this in
here. And let's see whether it does this. So I'm
gonna hit search. And you can see you successfully
solved the challenge error handling provoked an
error that is not very gracefully handle. Again,
this is a fantastic web application vulnerable web
application that is awesome for practicing your
your web application penetration testing skills.
Now, I talked about the URL that you should send
to your target. And that is the URL that will
essentially make them change their password or
without them knowing, given that they are logged
in to the web application or they have an account,
it will not work if they have not logged in.
Alright, so that's very important to understand.
And many people just you know, forget about this.
Now. Again, if you could have done this, you I
can log out again, and I can log in try and log
in now. And I can type in for example test I just
want to show you something very interesting here
test. And I can change the password, we already
changed it to password 123. Now before I do that,
I can just inspect the element here. And I'm
going to hit login. And I just wanted you to
check something out. All right now, let me just
expand this a little bit here. If we were to
look at the network, this will essentially shows
all the GET requests. So if I was to hit login,
you can see that if we are to look at the
get request here the login GET request,
you can go ahead and look at at the exact format
in which it was sent. You can look at the cookie
the it should give you the the authentication
token not to show it should give you the authentic
the authentication token. But that's something for
another day. Don't want to complicate you guys,
you can look at the cookie if you want to. And
you have all the responses right here. So there we
are. There's the authentication token and you can
see something very interesting in regards to the
token. Alright, so let me show you this right now.
Alright, so as I was saying, you can see. Alright,
so as I was saying, you can see that if we look
at the parameters, the password will be displayed
there, and it will be updated to the one that
we selected or specified in the script. Alright,
so remember, if you want to customize the cross
site scripting attack, you can do it through your
script. And where is lifted here. So there we are.
So you can change the password. The as you see,
we just got rid of the current password parameter,
which is a vulnerability on the site, but you can
change the password to whatever you want. And
now you might be asking, as I've mentioned, what
link do you send to the target and that is very,
very simple. If I was to run the script again,
and I change the password to maybe something else
like password 124, or 345, sorry, 345. Let me just
add that to the password. And I run the script on
an authenticated user, which is me. So let me copy
that. And it should change my account password.
And you can see once I log in, log out and try
logging in, it will have changed it successfully.
So let me just run it in here. So I'm going to
paste the new one in here. And I'm going to search
and there we are. So now it's changed my password.
And if I log out, and I try and log in with with
the old password, which is password 123, you can
see whoops, sorry, I think I typed that in wrongly
123 like so, fight login, there we are, you can
see that we entered the new password, and it did
work fantastic. So we were successfully able to
execute the script. And again, when if I just run
the script, again, this is the URL that you will
send to your target. Alright, so if I just copy
it, and I inspect it in my leafpad here, I really
love leafpad. I don't know that you guys love it,
too. If I just inspect it, you can see that this
indeed is a URL. And if the web application was
being hosted on a server, outside my local area
network, it would give you the website name, the
port, if it is port specific, and the URL here,
which as you can see is encoded. So what I
would recommend is that you copy this link here,
and you use a link shortener like bit fly or any
of the other Google shorteners, and you send that
to your target. And once they click on the link,
and if they already logged in to this specific
web application, it will update their password.
And you can essentially, you have the password
now because you've updated it. And you're all you
need is the email, which I'm pretty sure you must
be knowing if you're performing this attack. Or
you could just be gathering passwords of users,
all of which you can, you can send this link to
and are authenticated with the web application.
We're going to be taking a look at session
management. And in this video, particularly,
we'll be looking at cookie collection. Alright, so
as you know, you probably would have known what a
cookie is. Now there are three types of cookies
that we really need to be focusing on in this
section. And we will be focusing on in general.
The first one is the session cookies, which I'll
discuss in a while we then have the permanent
cookies and the third party cookies. So third
party cookies are really all to do with third
party API's that may be used. So for example,
if you're on a website that utilizes flashplayer,
you may find some cookies, that that are in relate
that are related to the Flash Player. So it's very
important that you understand how to collect these
cookies. And as well, we'll be looking at reverse
engineering them, but not really tampering with
them. Because I first want to explain to you guys
how everything is done. And then we can move on
into into finally tampering with them and seeing
if we can change them to give us access to give us
different type of of access. And where this comes
into play is when you're talking about session
cookies. And in this session cookies, we have the
the auth, the authentication token, and the D and
the unauthenticated token. So all to do with your
access on a web application or on a website. Okay,
so essentially, all the cookies that you can
probably ever get when you visit or you get
when you visit a website are they are generated
when you visit the website. And furthermore,
the cookies change when you authenticate with
the website and you or you log out right so when
you log in, you get a different set of cookies.
And when you log out, you get a different set of
cookies. This is where the whole idea of session
management comes into play and how cookies are
utilized for this system. So I'm currently running
OSU shop. So I showed you guys how to set that up.
Let me know if you found it helpful. So I have
it set up and open as it opened up in my browser.
Now what I'm going to be covering is how to
collect these cookies and understanding the
difference between an unauthenticated cookie
and the authenticated cookie. So Usually,
what I have, or what I use to my advantage
is if you're using Google Chrome or Firefox,
you you can get a cookie collection or a cookie
editor add on that allows you to edit the cookies.
But as I said, we're not going to be looking at
editing them right now, because we don't know
what to change in them, this video is going to
be focused on collecting them and then analyzing
them to see what information they have within
them. All right, so I've currently I reset this,
the OWASP juice shop. And the reason I did that
is just to start off fresh. And I said, we're
going to be using this for performing all of the
examples that we'll be showing you so that we can
learn all the concepts. So I'm just gonna, before
we log in, I just want to show you the first set
of cookies that we'll get once we were when we
visited the site. Don't worry about the other
links, we'll get to them in a second. Alright, so
I'm using the cookie editor right here, you can
find this same one for Firefox, that's what I'm
using. They are also other ones for Google Chrome,
if you want to do that. And in addition, we're
not going to be using any proxy, like burp suite
or the OWASP zap right now, because we're just
focused on using the browser tools. And of course,
these add ons here. So what I can do now is if I
just go right click, and I hit Inspect Element, we
have the, the developer tools right here. And if
we are to go into Once you've installed the cookie
editor, you can directly go into storage. And in
storage, you will, you will begin you will get the
cookies here and other values right here. But if
you it'll be better for you to understand what's
going on if you go into the cookie editor. Now
in the cookie editor, you can see that we have
two cookies that we've gathered here, and we have
the cookie consent status. And the the i o which
I'm not sure really what it does input output,
output, I'm probably guessing. So when it comes
down to the QB, consent status, we probably get an
idea of what of what this is. What this is asking
us. So when I when I opened up the website, it
gave me a prompt asking me like all websites will
ask you in 2018 to do is to accept their privacy
policy, in their privacy policies in regards to
their use of personal data and cookies. And the
reason is, is because cookies can can log or have
a lot of information about you. They contain a
lot of information about what your what you've
been doing. So this is why I've created this right
now before we move along, it's very important to
understand their role in session management. Okay,
so we need to look at the authentic authentication
tokens because that's where most of the magic
happens, as you would expect. So let me just close
this up. And let me just log in. So let me just
use the password there, the email that I used,
and the password, like so. And let me just log in.
I don't want to save the password. So I've logged
in now. And if I inspect the element, again,
you can see in the cookie editor, let that load,
it usually takes a while to load. There we are,
we have the token. Now the token, this token is
an authentication token. Alright, so when it comes
down, when it comes down to reverse engineering a
token, for example, let's use this as our example.
We essentially testing it for vulnerabilities
similar to a penetration test. Now you might be
a little bit confused. You might be asking, Well,
what what what do you mean by this? How can we
perform a penetration test on this token? Well,
this token is encoded. Alright. So this is if
we just copy this. I don't know whether you know
about this, but this is a JSON web token. Alright.
So it is it is a JSON web token. And you can use
the JSON Web Token decoder, I'll be posting this
link in the description. This is the one that
I prefer to use. If I am to paste this in here.
And you can see once I've pasted it in here, it's
going to give me all information. And I'm going
to help you understand what we've just done. So
essentially, what we have done is we have reverse
engineered what this web token is all about. So
now we need to look at what what it contains and
what type of authorities or privileges it's giving
to us. Because remember, this is an authentication
token. And it is unique to us because this will,
this will determine whether or not we're logged
into a site or we're logged out and what access
we have on the website. I'm pretty sure you
already know that. All right. So when it comes to
the header, now, this is very important. I've seen
many web people claiming to be bug bounty hunters
and they don't understand how the the web token is
even structured. What is the header the header is
separated from the payload. This is the header
right here, up until the first full stop that
is the header it's very important to understand
that because they are separated from each other.
In fact, the JSON web token is sorted into three
parts right here you have the you have the header,
you then have the payload until here. And then
finally you have the signature which is right,
right at the bottom here which is also separated
from the rest. Okay, so when it comes down to the
header, alright, the header is going to give
you the of the of the token. In this case,
we know it's a JSON web token, we then have the
algorithm, which is the hashing algorithm used,
which is the RS 256. And then the payload
now in the payload, this is where things get
really interesting as you would have expected, you
have the status, the status code here, the data,
if any data was passed the ID, we can always use
the ID. Two, we can always edit the ID to see what
else it can give us in terms of authentication,
because different types of identification or
identification tokens give us different types
of access. So, as essentially this is what I was
talking about, this is where you will scrutinize
the the the authentication token, and try and and
tamper with it to to see what different results
you can you can get. So remember, we can edit this
token, right, and we can edit anything about it.
And then we can finally copy it. And we can use
that in the OSB shop and paste it right here and
re authenticate with that new token and see what
results we can get. Now, of course, we're not
going to do that right now, because I wanted to
introduce you as to what information you're going
to find and what exactly is going on here. Okay,
so one step at a time. So you can see that
something interesting pops up here, something
extremely interesting, we have the email which
for some reason, in this token, we can see that
it's not very well designed because the email is
in plain text, which means which means if In any
case, or in any scenario, someone is able to get
this token in which I authenticated within a site,
they will have access to my email and my password.
But you must be saying, Well, I didn't see you
type out all of these random passwords here. Well,
I can easily guess that this is an MD five hashed
password, which means I can depending on the
on the strength of the password, I can decrypt
online in a second using any of the decryption
tools. So if I was to just copy this right now,
and I wanted to know the password, let's say this
wasn't even mine, this authentication token wasn't
even mine, and I found the the email and password,
all I needed to do was unmatched the password,
I can go to Mt five online.org, which is what I
use a lot. And I paste that hash right in here.
And I hit decrypt. And you can see, well, first
of all, it's gonna prompt me to enter capture
your storefront. This is this is getting really
annoying. Now, for some reason, it always does
that, as you can see, it's gonna, it's gonna find
the action. Of course, this is this is dependent
on the difficulty of the hash and whether or not
it can find it online. Okay, so you can see that
it will display the hash and the password in plain
text, which in this case was passed 123. Now,
of course, you can experiment with this.
And you can also experiment if, for example,
the authentication token that you found was using
a different encryption, or a hashing algorithm for
the password, the first thing you need to do is
identify what it's using, and then you go about
decrypting it. Now, I'm not going to be talking
about the other parts here, because that's a bit
that's a bit advanced. As you can see, by default,
the signature, the token signature failed,
which means we can tamper with this token, and we
can make changes to it. And we can authenticate
with it because it said, The OWASP juice shop is
is designed to be vulnerable. And this is where
you perform all of these tests. Okay, so when
it comes down to the payload, the most important
things are to look for the status, the ID and
obviously, if you can get any other information
in the data section, or in terms of the email and
the password, that's also very important. Now,
of course, it's not very easy to get a hold of
someone's of someone's token, but you can do
it but and then you are performing the penetration
test on the token, because if someone was to write
in the comment section of this video, what it was
to grab the the authentication token that belongs
to Facebook lets you have access to someone's
computer for a few seconds. And as to get the
authentication token, what would I be able to do?
Well, first of all, you have to test the security
of the token. And I can guarantee you that their
tokens are going to be very well secured and
performing the penetration or the penetration test
on them will be a different ballgame. So we'll be
looking at changing them or or tempering them to
give us different types of access. We're going to
be talking about HTTP attribute attributes and
cookie security. I am currently running OSU shop
and what I did is I started a fresh new instance.
So I unzipped a new OSU shop. That's because I
wanted to start afresh Now, of course, in the
previous video, we looked at cookie analysis
and tokens. But now we're going to look at how
at the security aspect of how these cookies are
secured and how you know how cookies are stolen
and how these can be exploited with with with
other exploits or functionality like cross site
scripting. Now you will get to what I'm saying
in a few seconds. So I have was used Stop running.
And I've created the same user and password as I
did last time. So it's a test@test.com, that being
the email and the password is password 123. Just
so you know. And I'll do that right now I'm just
going to log in, as you can see, test@test.com
and the password is password 123. So let me just
log in. And there you are. So I've logged in and
haven't solved any challenges. So when we talk
about cookie security, what do I mean? Well,
this can be done or can be inspected really
easily. Now, of course, for this, you're not going
to need any of the browser extensions or add ons,
because we'll just simply just be inspecting the
element here. So if we open inspect element and go
into storage, and we go into cookies, and select
the site, which is on localhost, you can see that
if I was to click on, for example, the token,
and we just look at the data, you know, that we
can see within the token, if we go to the HTTP
only section here, you can see that that is set to
false. Now, what does that mean? Well, that means
that we can potentially exploit this cookie and it
storage location in the sense that it is it is, it
is not secured. Now, I'll get to why and how this
is happening in the in a few seconds. Alright,
so if the value is set to false, it means that the
cookie can be accessed and written to now how can
one use this, you know, for potential attacks,
or Cookie, cookie stealing, as we know it. Now,
if you are an advanced web application penetration
test, and you know about cross site scripting, you
know, that usually attackers will use cross site
scripting, to steal cookies, by sending you links,
that then, you know, by sending you links to pages
on the site, that you're already authenticated to,
that have the the the malicious JavaScript
code that will then send your cookie,
your authentication cookie with your token,
etc, etc, to their attack server. And from that,
they can then use that to authenticate into your
account, it's not common, because mostly, the,
the cookies are usually secured. Now, you will
run into sites that have this and this is a very,
very big vulnerability in terms of severity. So if
you're a bug bounty hunter, this is in the medium
to low category, so not really a big exploit, but
still a very, very big problem that many, many,
you know, usually, I would like to say rookie
developers Miss, especially when dealing with
huge frameworks like node etc. I'm not going to
get too deep into that. So you can see that the
HTTP only is set to false. Now, what does this
mean? This means that we can use utilize a lot of
functionality to exploit or to display the broken
or even more to send this my cookie or you know,
my token, whatever you want to call it to a server
or to save it, alright, to grab it to steal it,
you know, simply put, so how can we exploit
this? Well, we can use cross site scripting,
and this is probably the most used method
for this. And to do this, we can simply,
we can use any of the, we can use the search, or
we can use the contact. But I like using search
because usually it is unfiltered. Now, when I
say this, I'm you know, many of you will say,
Well, most of the big sites, well, I'm not talking
about the big sites, the big sites, obviously have
to take this into consideration. I'm talking
about sites that are developed by small teams,
they usually don't take this into consideration.
So if I was to just type in a simple cross site
scripting script that will essentially display
my cookie right now as I'm authenticated. So to
do that, I'll just type in script. And for
this, we're using an alert here to display
to us so alert, and we're gonna say document,
whoops, stop, sorry, document, dot cookie. And,
and then we're gonna just close the script like
so. So this will display our cookie to us. Not
really helpful. But you can imagine if we were
to have this permanently posted, for example, as
a post here, and then whenever we send that link
to someone, and they click on it, we can customize
this JavaScript code to send their cookie to
our web server. And once we get their cookie,
you basically know what's gonna happen there. So
if I hit Enter to search, you can see that it's
going to display our cookie and our token, and
this is extremely dangerous. You might not get
the context, but I'll explain it in a second. So
essentially, this information can be passed and
sent anywhere across the world, provided that the
that your target clicks, clicks on a link in which
this, this script is executed. Now, the question
that you might be asking yourself as well, where
else can we post this in in sort of a malicious
way and I know that I sound malicious right now,
but I'll also get into how to mitigate this. And
again, mitigating It is really simple. Just set
your HTTP status or your HTTP attribute to true or
set it to on essentially securing your cookie now
You can see that once we have this, you saw in
the previous video, what we could do with such
information, and what info it contains in regards
to the user. And how we can, we can, you know,
crack the password. But for now let's focus on how
this can be utilized to steal the cookie or how
attackers do it. So you can also get insight if
you're a white hat. So usually I can post this in
here, I can put, you know, I can type the script
in here. But this is not, it's probably not the
best way of doing it. Because you essentially
have to convince the user to go into the search
bar and type this in. Not really the best of ways
about going about going about this. So usually,
we look for a page that allows us to, you know, to
post our own stuff, or to save this to a database
or to save it to the website itself. So we let's
try contact us. Alright, so contact us. Yeah,
that looks like a good place to start. So in the
comment you it already added our author for so in
the comment, we can enter, we can end our script
in Yeah, and this will probably probably be saved.
But we have to test it. Now. Of course, the cookie
stealing JavaScript code is not something that I'm
going to be telling you how to do, you can
probably perform a lot of Google searches,
it's part of the terms that I have to follow.
In regards to YouTube's YouTube's policies
about malicious content, and when what not,
so I'm not going to show you the exact code,
but I'll probably have it on my website, if you
want to take a look at it and experiment as to how
to send cookies to a another server or server that
belongs to you, for example. So to do this, so now
essentially, what I want to do is I want to save
this script, into the contacts section, because
I believe this is saved. If I looked, I looked at
the structure. And indeed, this is saved. So the
script is quite simple. So we can say, we can
give it a title because I know the feedback is
left like that. So we can say script test. And we
can close the script here. So scripts, but then we
have to include the the actual JavaScript code. So
yeah, so let's include this script within the main
one. So script. And then once we close this one,
we can then use the other script. So your script,
whoops script in, you can copy this code if
you want. By the way, let me just zoom in,
because a lot of you had actually talked to me
about that, that you couldn't actually see the
code. So script. And now we want to bring up
the alert. Now, of course, as I said, this is
not really useful, because all you're doing is
displaying the cookie to the user themselves,
once they visit this page, so you probably
get the idea. So script, alert, and we are
just simply just going to write the document, of
course, it's all sending it to a malicious server,
what I would have done is I would have used the
document dot cookie, and I would have appended it
to be sent in in the form of probably a PHP file
or a PHP GET request to my server, and then my
server would log all of the information being sent
back. So that's the concept there behind so we can
then close the script here. And sorry, we have to
actually close the script. Oops, sorry, my bad.
And then we close the script there. And finally,
we can close the final script ending here. So
script and there we are. And we can leave a
rating if we want to. And there is a CAPTCHA here
authentication 10 plus five. You You basically,
this is also an exploit here that you can enter.
Because if you look at this very basically, from
a simple perspective, the capture here is again,
is another false positive. And again, I know I'm
dragging this, I'm dragging it a lot. But But what
I'm trying to explain here is, if you are going
to, you're going to be performing a penetration
test on a web site, you need to understand that,
from the perspective of false positives, you
should not go after the big exploitations or the
big exploits first. Alright, so if I submit this,
as I know the structure of the OSU shop, this will
be submitted to one of the pages in which after
I click, or any other user who is authenticated
clicks, will will run that script, or this script
and will the cookie will be displayed on the
screen. And if you want to manipulate or use
your own script to send the cookie to your server,
by all means go and do that. I'm not condoning it.
So that is 75. And I hit submit. And what nots
wrong capture 10 plus five, actually, 25. Yes,
brackets of division multiplication addition, you
guys must be thinking I suck at math. So that is
25 plus five, plus 10. Sorry, that's 3535. And I
submit that whoops, we have to actually type our
code back in Sorry about that, guys. So we can
just type in script, and we're simply testing
test. And then after this, we can close the first
one. And script here. Whoops, sorry about that my
keyboard is quite a distance from me. Alert. And
my spelling mistakes are really annoying script.
And finally, we can use the document. My God, man
my typing document dot alert dot cookie, sorry,
we are we have already sent the alert, we will
use the doc document, that alert would essentially
display the entire webpage, document dot cookie.
And in here, we close the first script. And sorry,
the the initial script. And then we close the
last one year. So script. And we close that right
there. And finally, we can give this a rating and
resubmit. And that should submit it. I don't know
what the issue is here. And then there we are.
Also some Alright, so there we are. Thank you for
your feedback. So you did submitted there. Let me
zoom back out. Now, you can see that, where would
you go to launch the script? That's, that that
will be the question that you might be asking.
So on this in this structure, you can pretty much
experiment with all the other pages. And again,
I do recommend that you use you know directory
discovery tools, like there Buster go buster,
whatever is comfortable for you. So with this
in mind, if I was to just click on About Us,
you can see that that is where the the the
feedback in regards to contact is stored.
So there you are, there's the cookie. And if
I was to if I was to have implemented a script
that would send the cookie to my server, once
I access to this page as an authenticated user,
it would send my my session ID all of that good
stuff to my web server, I now be able to crack the
password and authenticate with your account. As
simple as that without ever knowing your password
without ever trying to have guessed it without
without ever trying to have exploited your system.
I exploited the web application. And because
of the the ability of the developer of the web
application to secure the cookies, I was able to
get into your account and god knows what else you
can do in that person's account. And this is you
know, this is tribute to my all my Facebook hacker
friends out there who think hacking Facebook is
about cracking and brute forcing. There you go,
you know, web applications can can be cracked
in or can be exploited in different ways. Now,
of course, as I said, it's going to get really
exciting as we move along with Duchamp. And
that's the reason I'm using it because it explains
how this can be done on a real website. And yeah,
we're going to be looking at OWASP juice shop. And
it seems to replicate what a real web application
would be a fairly poorly designed one. But the
thing I like about it is, it has varying levels,
levels of difficulty. And that's really,
really awesome. I have it set up on Heroku,
as you can probably see right over here. And that
works perfectly fine for me because I you know,
I wanted to set it up really quickly, I want to
run it on my local server, you know, using node
or Docker. That's really is, I really didn't have
the time to do that. But if you want to you can,
you can use Heroku. And it should be free for
you. So yeah, definitely go ahead and give it
a try. And you should have a an instance set up
for yourself. So you can go ahead and do it. And
it's giving us a prompt here telling us that
this website uses fruit cookies to ensure you
get the juiciest tracking experience. Now, from my
experience, I would hit accept the cookies because
essentially, that's what keeps track of your
progress. And yeah, that's pretty, that should
be quite good. Now as for my browser, I'm using
the latest version of Firefox and I have you know,
plugins or add ons like cookie editor. And that's
pretty much what we'll be needing In this video,
I hope and we don't have the the proxies here like
sorry, Foxy proxy to allow us to use things like
burp suite or zap whatever you want to use. OK,
so let's get started. Now the first challenge,
as I believe is to get the the scoreboard and
we should start from there. And to do this,
I think I have done this already. That's really
very simple. All we need to do is well first of
all before we actually do that, the interface is
quite simple. It is a juice shop as you probably
can see and could have understood and they
sold juice. Now the great thing that I like
about OSU shop is that this replicates a real
life a web application with you know, security,
misconfigurations, etc, etc. So if I log in,
you have your login page right over there, man,
you can create a new account if you want to, you
can search where the Contact Us page allows us to,
you know, essentially contact whoever is behind
the site. Then we have an About Us page. And
the thing I like about this is, as I said,
it replicates what I would call a real web
application. Now when you talk about, about the
scoreboard, I think that can be accessed really
quickly by going into scoreboard like so. So, you
know, we can just hit scoreboard. And if I enter,
that should give us the scoreboard. Alright,
so it gives us the notification once you've
completed the challenge, and the reason it does
this is to notify you of your progress. Remember,
this can be considered a capture the flag type
of challenge, but I wouldn't call it this I think
this is fantastic for essentially explaining the
concept here. Alright, so let me explain how the
scoreboard is essentially works. Alright, so
a scoreboard is as follows. Sorry about that,
if you had my phone, it always seems to do
that. So we have, we have the challenges
sorted in terms of difficulty. So we have a
one star, two star, three star, four star,
five star and six star. And they all have
various challenges within them. So for example,
the the difficulty sought in terms of star so you
get the idea, one star is quite easy, two stars,
you know, not so easy, we have three stars,
things are getting a bit sweaty here, four stars,
now we're talking five stars, I'm banging my head
on the wall, and six stars, that's going to take
you probably a few, a few days, or, you know,
hours depending on your determination. Alright,
so you can see it also gives you the gives you
the challenge names here. So if I click on the
two star challenges, you can go ahead and look at
the challenges there. And we brought I think in
the previous videos, we covered a lot of the two
star and three some of the four star challenges
that we wanted to go through. So the three star
challenges are where things get really awesome,
because it does start logging in with other
users. And there's a bit of cross site scripting,
I'm not going to go through all of that,
let's start off with what we can do. Alright,
so the first challenge in the first is access the
administration section of the store, or right,
so I'm guessing we have to try and log in, I
think I've done this, this is the first challenge,
we have to access a confidential document provoked
an error. That is not gracefully, very gracefully
handled, not to show that is let us redirect you.
I'll try and cover as many as I can. In one video,
we have cross site scripting attack. This was
simple. I think we covered this. So yeah, we can
pretty much run that in one of these right over
here. So script, and alert, as it already gives
you hints these are very, very easy. So I can
just say test. Have I given the OP Sorry, my bad.
So yeah, there we are test. And we close that up.
And we also close the script right over here. And
we hit Enter. And there we are. So that is one of
the challenges solved, hopefully did pop up there.
So if we go back to the scoreboard, it still
tells us for some reason, the web application is
too low, it's not told us that we have performed a
reflected cross site scripting, all those I don't
know, right, so reflected. Anyway, we'll get to
that when we get to it. So if we inspect the login
page, what we can do is we can create a user. So
I'm going to create a user here. And I'll just use
a simple user here called test@test.com. And the
password or call that password. And I'm going to
repeat the password here. And I'll just call the
password password. And I'm just going to use name
of your favorite pet. And I'm just going to say
dog right over here. I'm going to hit register.
And we're going to save that. Alright, so I can
log in now. Did I log in with the correct test?
Yeah, there we are. And we're going to log in,
and we are logged in. Alright, so let me just
zoom out. So the interface does not really crashed
on us. Let me just get rid of that. All right,
so it's sorted out really well. We have the
language selector here your basket, which
essentially allows you to select your to view the
items in your basket, you then have your coupon
if you want, if you want to use a coupon and you
have your checkout, which essentially I believe
takes you to the the OWASP juice shop, donate
page if I'm not wrong. Let's just see if that
is correct. Yeah, yeah. So if you want to support
the project, I would, you know, you can donate to
them. It's a really great project. I really do
recommend that if you can you do so. So you can
change your password, which is awesome. I think
we also took a look at this and how to change
it using using the GET requests. Contact us where
you can necessarily write in, you can contact the
person via the site or the administrator as I
would believe. You can comment, recycle recycle
what this requester recycling box so you can type
in liters here that has a selector. Alright, okay,
that's not too bad. We have a complaints board.
And the scoreboard itself here, which for some
reason, keeps doesn't really load. So let's try
and work on the first section. As I mentioned,
I'll try and cover as much as I can here. And
you have the About Us here that has some sort of
Let's see some sort of checkout or boring terms
of views. Let me just check the scoreboard what
exactly are we supposed to do? Because access the
administration section? What's in the two star
here? login with the administrator. All right, so
we're trying to access the administration section.
So let's try and access that right over here.
So I'm just gonna type in admin administration,
like so I'm gonna hit Enter. And yeah, that was
pretty easy. And we get the email right over here,
admin and do shop. That's the admin email. And we
have all the emails right over here. So we have
you met juice, juice shop, Bender, and some other
uses. And we have also, yeah, alright, so we got
the registered users customer feedback, and the
recycling requests that have been posted so far.
Which means you're starting from the basics.
So I think we can try and log in with admin,
but we don't know the password. So yeah, so I'm
just going to log out. And let's see if we can log
in with the password here. admin, I do shop, and
I probably I'm probably guessing we have to use
SQL injection. And in this case, I think I know
what to do, because I have done this before. But
it has been changed quite a bit since the last
time because I think in the previous versions,
it was with admin only, there was no domain
oza username, I'm not too sure. Anyway,
let's try and see if we can throw some
errors here. So if I log in, alright,
so that means you have to provide a password. So
let me just try and use the single quotation. And
let's see if that Yeah, it does throw an error.
And there Yeah, we completed the other challenge,
which you successfully solved the challenge error
handling provacan errors here. So essentially,
performing error enumeration, if that's something
you've never heard of, it's essentially where you
just try and see all the CE o 's fuzzing really
just throwing, you know, information at the
system, seeing how it responds. And we get here
the query. So we are performing SQL injection,
because as you can see, tells us here we have
the the query right over here, which is telling
us select and what this is saying is select
all entries from the user table where emails
are equal to and we specify the single quotation.
And the password is what is this? This looks like
a hash? What hash is this? Let me just check. I'm
think it might be MD. Five, I'm not too sure. Let
me just check this hash identifier. And we just
paste that in there. Sorry about that. Let me
just paste that in there. Yeah, this is an MD
five hash. So that probably let's just see if
we can decrypt that or decode that. So I'm just
gonna say MD five decrypter, or something like
that. Let's just see if we can do this online
really quickly. Come on, come on. I want to see
what error because that's, that's a password.
Let's decrypt that. And we'll for some reason,
it's taking too much time here. So yeah, yeah,
it's essentially hashing the password. Alright,
interesting stuff there. We actually now know that
the password is being hashed, obviously, you know,
with the Mt. Five, hashing algorithm or protocol,
whatever you wanna call it. So original. And yeah,
that is the query statement there. So we can try
some basic SQL injection. And some of the basic
ones to log into admin or to essentially log
into the administration, the admin panel is,
now the thing that's weird is are we going to use
the password do we're trying to get authentication
so that means let me disclose that. That means
if we just throw the error one more time,
or get the when you were able to get the query
here. So we are saying select actually start from
there. Select from users, so select all queries,
all entries from the user table, from where email
use the table. So there's users Alright, so the
user, the user table as email and password, okay,
I follow now. So that means we can try we can
try, we can try and use the or statement here.
And probably we can use the not statement if we
are going to Yeah, that will make a lot of sense,
but we only using email so we'll keep the
single quotation. So what that means is,
is if you know about SQL injection, hopefully I
can explain what's going on here. So we know that
the password is being hashed, we're saying select
from the table where email and password. So that's
the statement. So select from the table for sort
of select from the users table where the email
and password is going to be equal to is going to
be equal to what we have entered. But remember,
the the password has to be has to stay as the
single quotation. So that means your we are
going to be using the or so this is basic use,
you guys should be knowing this, but if you want
me to cover it, let me know so or equals or so or
one equals one. And the other ways of doing this,
I think I'll post a cheat sheet in the description
section, you can check it out for yourself just
to get up to scratch with what's happening. So
what we're saying is we're using the or the or
the syntax of or is very simple. It's where we
have the what's happening here is we're seeing,
we're seeing Okay, so if you know the syntax
for how a query is made in SQL, it's really
very simple. So we're saying select from, from
the table, remember, this is specifying a table,
not a column. So it says select from the
users table from select from the users table,
email password, so comparing and then we say
all the new specify the condition with a value,
we can enter our into fields. So we can say the
value of the email can always be changed. And we
obviously know that that is the first account
that was created. And the password is going to
remain the same. So we hit login. And yeah, we
get still keep on getting an error here. Now,
that is weird. No, because if I specify there is
no comment here, or one equals one, yes. So it is
working. So you can see. So select from users,
where one equals one and password. Yeah, so we
want to nullify and password we don't want and
there. So for that we use the user comment here.
And there we are. Excellent. So we're able to log
in to the administrators use account. Alright,
so let me explain what happened there. So as I
said, the the syntax of the query was as follows
we're selecting from the users table, we're
selecting the email and password and comparing
them to each other. So they have to match show
up, you're performing a query, a simple query,
and what we said is, or that's a conditional
statement. So we're saying or that we specify
the condition where the first value is going to
be equal to the the, the first one is going to
be equal to one, and we nullify the, the password
where the password was we're essentially removing
authentication. And we are what because we're
including the comment syntax for SQL. Alright,
so that was pretty simple. But now, the thing
that's bothering me is we don't have the
password. So let me just check the scoreboard.
And let's see what progress we've made so far.
So have access administration section that's
not in here that is in here. So log in with the
administrators use account. Marino the password.
So I think that's how we're going to be logging
in. We know the email, because if I just go back
into administration here, administration, I hope
the video is not getting too long. So we have the
admin. We have the admin email here. Um, oh, yes,
yes, yes, yes, we have the token. So if we inspect
the element, and we go into the cookie editor,
for example, we can use that or you can just use
storage. But I should have done it, you know,
from the cookie editor from the beginning. So we
have the the token here. And I talked about this
in my other video actually went through this
with the token. So. So we're gonna say token,
I think the site was it's a JSON tokens, a token,
decode, and should be the first site here, the
JSON web token. So jw t.io. That's an excellent
site. And we talked about this. So if you want to
watch that video, I'll post it in the description.
So you can check it out. And the email is admin.
So that's the authentication token, and that
gives us all the information we need. All right,
so we have the password here. But again, what is
this hashed into? That looks like MD five again,
but let me just confirm, and let's see what
that gives us. So the password is hashed,
as we know with MB five, so let's just confirm
hash identifier, because there we are. Yeah,
it is MD five. So let's just decrypt that one more
time. So I'm just gonna paste in that hash there.
I'm just going to decrypt let's give that a few
seconds. Oh, my God, man, all the traffic lights.
And let's hit verify. And yeah, there we are. The
password is I mean 123 Yeah, that's that's pretty
basic, but again, replicating common practice
that you would find. So what was the email? Oh,
boy, what was the email? Let me just log back
out. Correct. All right. So let me just use the
statements. Oh, yeah. So we're logging in. So all
one equals one, because we're all the waters the
I think we can access the the middle from the
administration. Sorry about that, guys. I know,
I'm getting really mixed up. Well, we're
not logged in yet. So anyway, let me just
log in. And we can do the administration here.
stration. And the admin I do shop at juice shop,
a juice.up. Yeah, that's there to confuse
people. So you can guess it? And we're
logging in with that. And the password is
admin 123. We're going to log in, and yeah,
fantastic. So you solve the challenge password
strength. So that was the problem there. That's
the vulnerability that they're trying to say
exists. So you know, again, password strength is
something that people don't take into account,
login within message user credentials, without
previously changing them or applying SQL. Could
you have done this with SQL injection? Probably,
I'll have to cover SQL injection, because we know
SQL injection is one of those things that's really
dependent on the query. So let me just go back to
the scoreboard here. I don't understand what else
is left. There's still a lot of stuff that have
to cover. I talked about cross site scripting,
but I think I'll cover that in the next video.
We'll explain it again. What is the what is the
the confidential document error handling? Or we
don't have anything much they're actually someone
else's basket? I did that. What else should I want
to cover here? Let's look at these ones right over
here. So yeah, so the authentication area here
is where I want to look at. I think that's where
I'm going to end this video. I know, I haven't
covered any advanced stuff. But hopefully that's
like an introduction. So where we, where we have
been able to log into the administration in the
administrators account, we are able to get the
scoreboard the administration panel, what else
were we able to do? We were able to provoke
an error, not saying no nothing really complex
there. And we were able to log in with the admin
tree at the administrators group user credentials.
Now we looks like we can actually get access to
Max's search original users credential so again,
another user that we can try and get access into.
Yeah, that's gonna be it for this video. Guys. If
you found value in this video, please leave
a like down below. If you have any questions
or suggestions, let me know in the comment
section on my social networks or on my website,
and I'll be sure to leave your reply and I'll
be seeing you in the next video. Peace, guys.